SAM FEW MINUTES PAST.
BLOG IN RESPECT OF EVERYBODY'S
TIME RIGHT TO US THIS --
ASSEMBLY SELECTOR COME HE
HEARING ON THE HATE CRIME.
AND GOOD AFTERNOON AND WELCOME
TO THE PUBLIC HEARING ON IDEAS
FOR LATER BILLION AWARENESS WITH
ASSEMBLY SELECT COMMITTEE ON
HATE CRIME.
AND THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR
INTEREST IN BEING HERE I WANT
ESPECIALLY. TO ALLOW FOR A GOOD
SUPERVISOR DAVE CORTESE ANTHONY
STARBUCKS WOULD.
BE CORRESPONDS DURING THIS
DEBATE THANK YOU VERY.
THE BY THE BUSINESS OKAY WORD
THE AND THIS BILL --
FOR COME TO YOU AJW TIMBER --
NAMES KANSEN CHU I'M THE CHAIR
OF THE ASSEMBLY SELECT COMMITTEE
ON A CRIME.
AND I'M HAPPY TO BE CO HOSTING.
THIS HEARING WAS OUR SUPERVISOR
PHONE SENATE --
A COUNTY AND IS THERE ANY OTHER
YOU LACK OF THE OFFICE BILLS IN
THE AUDIENCE.
BY HAVING BY THAT --
MANY OF MEMBERS.
OF TOWN FROM FROM THE AS THE
STATE RESPONSE TO THE RISE OF
HATE CRIME THROUGHOUT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
ADDITION TO MYSELF COMMITTEE IS
MAKE UP ALL TEN OF MY COLLEAGUES
INDEX CALIFORNIA STATE ASSEMBLY.
THE ASSEMBLY SELECT COMMITTEE ON
HATE CRIME SERVE SO TOOL TO
FOSTER COMMUNITY ENGAGED.
AND OPEN DIALOGUE.
AND IN COLLABORATION. FOR ETHNIC
AND RELIGIOUS ORGANIZATION G. B.
TQ GROUPS.
LAW ENFORCEMENT NONPROFIT AND
OTHER ORGANIZATIONS.
AS MUCH AS CALIFORNIA HAS
STRIVED BE THE MOST INCLUSIVE
PROGRESSIVE STATE IN THE UNITED
STATES.
WE STILL HAVE OF THE HIGHEST
NUMBER OF HATE CRIME AND THE
BEST NUMBER OF HATE GROUPS AND
THE SHARP INCREASE IN THE PAID
AND BILLION RELATED.
CRIME EVEN THOUGH THOSE CRIMES
ARE GENERALLY AN UNDER.
THE REPORT IT.
SO I SHOULD HAVE ASKED THE THE
THE STATE AUDITOR SOFT.
AND WE DID A HATE CRIME ALTHOUGH.
I BELIEVE WE ALSO DOWNLOADED
FROM THE THE STAY OFF OF HER
WHAT OF WEBSITES.
WHAT I HAVE POSTED VERY THAT
HEARINGS ABOUT THE HATE CRIMES
TODAY?
THIS WILL BE ALL OVER YOU IN
SCHOOL.
CHILDREN'S ARE FACING
DISCRIMINATION IN SCHOOL.
AND I WANT TO PROVIDE AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO HEAR ABOUT
THE IMPACT.
AND MOST IMPORTANTLY THE
SOLUTIONS. TO LOW HERE FROM OUR
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS COMMITTEE ALL
ADDITIONS AND SCHOOL
REPRESENTATIVE SO THAT PRETTY
MUCH BREAKING INTO.
OF A SPEED OF OF PANELS AT THE
FIRST TRIAL WOULD BE.
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS FROM BOTH
SANTA CLARA COUNTY EAST AND
OTHER MEDIA COUNTY.
AND WE JUST.
READ TO RECOGNIZE A ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ASH KALRA.
JOIN US.
RIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THIS THE A HAND UP THERE.
I THINK YOU USED.
TO THE DOCTOR'S OFFICE.
OKAY BUT WITH OFFERED YOU ARE A
LIFE TO GIVE TO PULL TO MY
COLLEAGUE --
ASAHARA TO SAY THE WORDS.
I THANK.
THE CHAIR KANSEN SOON AS I WANT
TO START BY THANKING YOU --
THE HAVE THE LIMITED SCOPE AND
AND AND TIME AND ENERGY OF WHAT
WE CAN DO RUMOR TAKEMOTO BECAUSE
WE THAT IT'S INCUMBENT UPON US
AS LEADERS FROM SACRAMENTO.
COUNTIES AT OUR CITIES.
AND CERTAINLY OTHER SCHOOLS DO
WHATEVER WE CAN TO COMBAT --
CRIMES IN JENIN.
ALSO MORE.
AT THE GROUND LEVEL OF ENSURING
THAT WERE OF THE DOING THINGS
THE COMPASSIONATE LOVING WAY IN
THERE FOR ME THE TRUTH THE
LEARNING ABOUT OUR NEIGHBORS.
AND NOT WAITING UNTIL SOMETHING
HAPPENS BUT RATHER --
DOING THINGS PROACTIVELY THAT
ARE PRODUCTIVE.
AND ABBAS BECOME CLOSER AS A
COMMUNITY AND SO FOR THAT I'M
GRATEFUL TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHU
AND AND I WILL SAY THIS --
OFTEN DOES.
HAS WOULD AGREE.
THAT WERE VERY LUCKY.
SACRAMENTO --
TO BE ABLE TO REPRESENT SANTA
CLARA COUNTY HIDE --
AND I KNOW THAT --
ASSEMBLY SHOULD ALSO AS THE
GREAT BENEFIT OF ALSO REPRESENT.
AS WELL THE FOR ME SINCE I ONLY
REPRESENT TO THE SOUNDS A AND
SANTA CLARA COUNTY IT MAKES.
MY JOB MAKES OUR JOB SO MUCH
EASIER BECAUSE CERTAINLY.
SOME OF OUR COLLEAGUES FROM
OTHER PARTS OF THE STATE DON'T
ASSEMBLY SUPPORT FROM THE COUNT
DOLLARS OF THAT APART FROM
AROUND FOR STILL ALICE HAVE
SUPPORT AS WELL AS DIFFERENT
IDEOLOGIES.
A FORTUNATE THAT --
FROM CENTERS A. B. FROM SANTA
CLARA COUNTY IN PARTICULAR
READERS LIKE.
VISOR CRITICIZING CHAVEZ THAT
WERE ALWAYS ON THE SAME PAGE IS
ABOUT MOVING FORWARD AND AND
IT'S ALWAYS ABOUT.
DATING AND SERVING OUR COMMUNITY
AND I NEVER HAD THE SECOND BEST
WITH THE COUNTY IS GOING TO BE
SUPPORTING WORDING AND LIKE WHAT
IS -- KANSEN
AND I WAS GOING TO DO WHATEVER
WE CAN TO SUPPORT THE WORK OF
OUR LOCAL COUNTS BECAUSE THEY'RE
ON THE RIGHT SIDE OF THE ISSUES.
ALWAYS ON ENGAGED IN COMMUNITY
SO -- THAT'S
WHY I THINK IT'S ACTUALLY
APPROPRIATE RABBIT THIS HEARING
WHERE --
WITH OUR FRIENDS PROVIDES.
US WITH AS CHAVEZ AND CORTESE
WHO WE WORK VERY CLOSELY WITH --
WOMEN SACRAMENTO ON A WIDE RANGE
OF ISSUES AND AND WE GREATLY
BACK MARK COUNTY AGAIN
SUPPORTING OUR WORK SO FOR THAT
I'M GRATEFUL AND I'M.
CERTAINLY GREAT FOR EVERYONE TO
ONE FOR BEING HERE THANK YOU.
THEM TAKE YOUR FAMILY MEMBER
KALRA IN THE OLD.
WHICH IS SOME IMAGE --
AND THANK YOU OF ALSO BEING HERE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA --
IN THE IN THE COUNTY HAS A LONG
HISTORY TRADITION.
AND ASKED OF A RIVAL TEAM.
THESE LEGISLATIVE HEARINGS HERE
IN IT IS REALLY A PRIVILEGE TO
DO IT I THINK IT'S PRO WHICH IN
A SET FOR COMMITTEE TO
STAKEHOLDERS UP TO TO BE ABLE TO
COME FORWARD AND INTERRUPTS.
THEIR OF MEMBERS OF THEIR
LEGISLATIVE DELEGATION AND IN
THIS CASE THIS WAS COUNTY
SUPERVISORS --
WHO AS YOU JUST A LITTLE?
TO A AS BOTH JUST A LITTLE TOO
IN -- I
ACTUALLY.
IMPLEMENT ACTIONS TO TO DEAL
WITH ISSUES --
THAT.
ARE VERY FRUSTRATING FOR PEOPLE
STILL POINT OF WHEN THEY SEE
THEM OCCURRING IN OUR COMMUNITY.
SOMEONE THANK YOU OF YOU ON ONE
THING SUPERVISOR SHOP IS
PARTICULARLY.
FOR REALLY HAVING THAT SIXTH
SENSE OF OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS
TO PARTICULARLY AFTER THE
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN TO REALIZE.
THAT WE NEED TO CONVENE FOLKS
HERE.
UP AROUND THESE ISSUES SO WE HAD.
WE WILL TAKE SOME CREDIT I THINK.
FOR CONVENING HEARINGS --
EIGHT OR GO A LITTLE LESS THAN A
YEAR AGO JANUARY OF THIS YEAR.
AROUND IMMIGRATION AND WOMEN'S
ISSUES BUT THE CREDIT --
SQUARELY WAS SUPERVISOR SHOWBIZ
SCHOOL COMPACT ABOUT.
TWENTY THIRTEEN FOR TAKING SOME
OF THESE ISSUES ARE GIOTTO'S IN
INTO THE PUBLIC ARENA HERE AT
THE COUNTY --
AROUND HUMAN TRAFFICKING AROUND
HATE CRIMES IN IN RAMBLING SO
I'M SURE.
SHIPLEY TO STAY.
UP INTERN WHY SHE FEELS IS SO
IMPORTANT.
FOR BOTH THE COUNTY AND THE
STATE TO BE.
FULLY ENGAGED.
AS RECENTLY AS YESTERDAY --
I IT WAS ASKED TO SIT DOWN WITH.
A WOMAN WHO IS IN THE SECOND OF
BUSINESS AND SECOND IN THIS
COMMUNITY --
WHO WANTED A LITTLE BIT OF MY
TIME TO EXPLAIN --
THAT HER DAUGHTER HAD BEEN
SEXUALLY ASSAULTED --
DOES ALL SCHOOL STUDENT.
ACTUALLY ON CAMPUS IN THIS
COMMUNITY AND COURSON AKA
REFERENCE THE CASE OR SPECIFIC
NAMES.
AFTER WHAT WE SALT WILL BE SEEN
JUST RECENTLY --
WITH DOCTOR FORD'S TESTIMONY
BEFORE --
FOR COMMITTEE THE UNITED STATES
SENATE.
IN THE BOWLING THAT OCCURRED ON
A NATIONAL LEVEL.
NOT OVER SOMEBODY'S RACE CREED --
FOR THE JUST GENERAL THE WAY THE
LOCAL BOOK WITH THEIR POLITICAL.
BLUE TO USE AND MUCH MUCH DEEPER
THAN THAT.
A TO SPEED IN THE ADULT
ESSENTIALLY BOLTED ON A NATIONAL
LEVEL ABOUT COMING OUT --
WITH FAX IN TESTIMONY ON A
SEXUAL ASSAULT THAT OCCURRED
DURING THE TEENAGERS --
TABLES AS ALL THAT THAT'S AN
ISSUE THAT WE NEED TO DO. TO
MAKE SURE IS ON THE AGENDA.
AND I HOPE.
THAT ANYONE.
WOULD THAT ASPECT.
OF INTIMIDATION.
OF IN FEAR.
OF THAT [INAUDIBLE]
SUPPRESSES.
THE KIND OF INFORMATION THAT WE
NEED.
OF WHEN THOSE KIND OF ASSAULTS
ARE GOING UP AND UP AMONG OUR
OUR YOUNG PEOPLE IN THIS
COMMUNITY.
I HOPE THAT YOU COME FORWARD --
IN THE CASE THAT I HAD --
THE RED LISTEN TO YESTERDAY I
CAN ONLY THINK.
OF HOW MUCH FOR YOUR THAT YOUNG
WOMAN FIFTEEN YEARS OLD.
TODAY THIS IS HAPPENING NOW NOT.
OF FORTY OR FIFTY YEARS AGO LIKE
WE HEARD WITH DR FORT.
WITH THE CASE IT IS HAPPENING
NOW WITH A FIFTEEN YEAR OLD
ALTERED BY.
A SENIOR IN HIGH SCHOOL --
ON HER OWN HIGH SCHOOL CAMPUS --
IN WHAT KIND OF BOWLING CAN IT
WILL OCCUR.
WHEN THE INDIVIDUAL --
COMES OUT INTO THE PUBLIC IN
BECOMES AN ADVOCATE SO THAT THAT
DOESN'T HAPPEN TO SOMEONE ELSE
SO I JUST WANTED TO PUT THAT OUT
THERE IS SOMETHING THAT I HOPE.
YOU'RE IF YOU'RE COMMITTEE
CONTINUES TO LOOK AT A
SUPPLEMENT YOU --
IN ADDITION.
ALL OF THE THE EDITOR BY THIS
WORK -- IN
THE COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT WORK --
RABBIS REALLY BUILDING THAT
WE'RE GONNA BE TALKING ABOUT
THANK YOU. THREE ZERO FIVE ZERO
AYE.
ONE SUPERVISORS CHAVEZ TO GIVE
US A OPENING REMARKS.
THANK YOU AND THE FIRST ONE I
THINK ALL OF YOU VERY MUCH FOR
BEING HERE.
AND I SEE WE HAVE SOME VERY
YOUNG MEMBERS HERE.
TO AND CHILD MAYBE.
OF DOES MY GRANDDAUGHTER.
AND AND SOAK.
LET'S GIVE A ROUND OF APPLAUSE
FOR BEING HERE THANK YOU.
WE'RE STARTING VERY YOUNG RIGHT
WE WANNA GET THE MAIN GATE I'M
I'M REALLY EXCITED TO HAVE --
REALLY BOTH ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
KALRA AN ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU
HERE AND I JUST WANT TO THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR DOING THIS AND
SAY.
A COUPLE THINGS.
ABOUT THE WORK WE'RE DOING AND
AND I MAKE A POINT ABOUT SOME OF
OF WHAT.
IT WHAT DAVE JUST RAISED SO
FIRST OF ALL WEEK.
IT'S EASY TO THINK ABOUT SANTA
CLARA COUNTY AS KIND OF A SAFE
PLACE AND I DAVE WHAT YOU JUST
POINTED OUT IS THAT WE HAVE SO
MUCH WORK TO DO AND YOU'RE GOING
TO HELP US UNDERSTAND WHAT.
WHAT MORE WE CAN DO ON THIS END?
AND I ALSO JUST WANTED TO SAY
THAT -- DAVE --
AND BY LEAD RE M. HEARINGS HERE
ONE THAT WAS FOCUSED ON WOMEN
ONE THAT WAS FOCUSED ON ON HATE
CRIMES IN REAL CLIMATE --
AT THE OTHER THAT WAS FOCUSED ON
IMMIGRATION AND THIS WAS REALLY
A RESPONSE TO THE NATIONAL
ELECTION AS IT OCCURRED BECAUSE
IN MANY OF YOU WERE HERE.
BECAUSE PEOPLE REALLY DIDN'T
KNOW WHAT WHAT WERE THE
IMPLICATIONS OF HAVING --
REALLY A BULLY RUNNING THE HOW
DO WE TALK TO OUR CHILDREN ABOUT
IT HOW DO WE BETTER UNDERSTAND
THAT.
SO OUT OF THAT WE CAME UP WITH A
NUMBER OF A POLICIES AND ONE
THAT I WANTED TO SHARE WITH YOU
WAS A COUNTY.
ANTI BULLYING POLICY.
AND IN THE IN THE NEXT MONTH --
THE STAFF WILL COME BACK WITH
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THAT
POLICY BECAUSE WE BOTH WANTED TO
BE ABLE TO MAKE SURE THAT ALL OF
OUR OUTWARD FACING ORGANIZATION.
ORGANIZATIONAL BURKE AN
INDIVIDUAL WORK REALLY WAS --
UNDERSTOOD TO THE PLANS OF BEING
WELCOMING AND INCLUSIVE AND SO
THERE'S A LOT OF WORK TO BE DONE
THERE BUT I'M VERY EXCITED ABOUT
THAT.
AND I'LL JUST CLOSE BECAUSE I I
THAT NOR STUFF GOING TO TALK
ABOUT --
SOME OF THE WORK THEY'RE DOING
THEY'RE DOING --
TO MAKE THIS OBSERVATION.
I HAD NO IDEA --
HOW PERVASIVE BOWLING WOULD BE
WHEN I WAS A CHILD?
THROUGHOUT OUR LIVES I THINK WE
OFTEN THINK OF BOWLING IS
SOMETHING THAT HAPPENS ON
COLLEGE CAMPUSES ARE HIGH SCHOOL
CAMPUSES NOT SO MUCH BECAUSE
WHAT REALLY. FOR CHILDREN.
AND THE TRUTH OF THE MATTER IS
THAT WE HAVE A WHOLE NEW NORM.
THAT'S BEING ACCEPTED AT A
NATIONAL LEVEL.
ANY OTHER PART OF THAT THAT SORT
OF A STANDING TO ME IS THAT DAVE
AND I WERE HEARING YESTERDAY.
WHERE WE HAD AN ADVOCATE FOR THE?
AT IT WITH SENIORS AT SENIOR
ORGANIZATIONS AND SENIOR HOUSING.
AND SO I I SAY THAT BECAUSE IF
IT IS A IT'S A HUMAN DIRECTION
THAT WE'RE TRYING TO ADDRESS IS
ONE OF THE REASONS I'M SO
EXCITED THAT WE'RE DOING THIS
I'M REALLY INTERESTED IN HEARING.
FROM ALL OF YOU --
THE VERY GOOD WORK THAT YOU'RE
DOING AND AGAIN I WANT TO THINK
A DATE OF AND KANSEN ARCH.
FOR JUST ALL OF YOUR LEADERSHIP
AMAZING WORK AND I'M EXCITED TO
HEAR FROM ALL OF YOU.
THANK USE OF WRITERS I'M
ASSEMBLY BEFORE WE MOVE MOVE FOR
A MOVIE I LIKE HELL BUT FEW
HOCKEY NIGHT AND TO ENSURE THAT
WE HEAR FROM EVERYONE.
I WOULD LOVE TO TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO RECOGNIZE.
THAT THIS PUBLIC HEARING WILL
FOCUS ON A RE SENSITIVE TOPIC.
IN THAT ASPECT EVERYONE TO
CONDUCT IN THE REALLY RESPECTFUL
MANNER.
I HAVE SAID THE PROPERLY TO KEEP
THERE BUT PRESENT TURNED TO THE
I'M A LOCATOR WHICH IS ROUGHLY
SEVEN MINUTES I APOLOGIZE I KNOW.
THE OFFICE.
IN ONE OF OUR OF A DISTINCT
PENELAS CAN'T EIGHT PROBABLY.
SEVEN HE ON THE LIST --
TO KEEP TIME WITHIN SEVEN MINUTE.
AND TO EACH THOSE WHO WILL BE IF
THE EACH FINAL WILL BE FOLLOWED
BY A Q. AND A PORTION. FOR
MEMBERS ON DAVIS AND ASKING
QUESTIONS OF OF TO PRESENT. TO
BE THREE PALO.
IN TIME FOR THE PUBLIC COMMENT
AT A AT THE END.
SO.
THE BAR.
ALL THE PANELISTS ARE EITHER
HAVE ALSO I'M NOT GOING.
TO BE TOO MUCH TIME TO INTRODUCE
SOME WELL WE'LL SEE A STAR WAS
THE FIRST CAPITAL AND WOULD HAVE
DID IT --
THE ASSISTANT DISTRICT ATTORNEY
FROM SANTA CLARA COUNTY AND
EARNED AND ALAMEDA COUNTY SO
PLEASE JOIN ME IN WELCOME.
IN JAMES GIVE.
GIPSON SERVE THE PERIOD --
RES.
DREADING IS A BUSINESSMAN.
DID DID DISTRICT ATTORNEY FROM
ALAMEDA COUNTY.
GOOD AFTERNOON ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KALRA.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
TO SUPERVISOR PERTAIN THE AT
SUPERVISOR SHOP AS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR IT WRITING AND
SALAS COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE TO DISSIPATE AND THAT
IMPORTANT HEARINGS HEY --
I AM HERE REPRESENTING MY OFFICE
AND STRICT ATTORNEY NANCY --
MAPPERLEY WE ARE AS AN OFFICE
AND SEARCH NEEDS A MALADY HAVE
BEEN FOR YOU.
KNOW COMMITTED [INAUDIBLE]
TO WORKING.
IMPROVE OUR TOWN IS RESPONSE.
TO BOTH HE IS AS WELL AS
BULLYING WITH OUR SCHOOLS AND AS
COUNCIL MEMBER.
I'M SUPERVISORS OF AS MENTIONED
OUTSIDE SCHOOL AS WELL.
WE HAVE MANY DIFFERENT PROGRAM
AND OUR EFFORTS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES. TO ADDRESS WHAT WE
ARE NOW SEEING AS A HUGE RISE
AND NOT ONLY HATE CRIMES BUT
HATE REALLY SPEECH AND HE OR
LET'S CALL BACKS WE HAVE OUR
CREATE IT UP HOTLINE FOR MEMBERS
OF OUR COMMUNITY TO CALL IN.
THE MONARCH TWENTY FOUR BURKE OR
IS IT SEVEN DAYS A WEEK AT
RESPOND TO IN REAL TIME.
THE REAL PERSON HAVE MORE
BILINGUAL --
FOLKS WITH IN OUR OFFICE WHO
THREW IT.
VERY MUCH AFFECTED BY BULLYING
WITHIN THE SCHOOL SETTING THAT
IS NOT BECAUSE OF THEIR ABILITY
TO THRIVE WITHIN SCHOOL BUT ALSO.
OR DESIRE TO ATTEND SCHOOL AT
ALL WE'RE SEEING A RISE IN
SCHOOL REFORM IS ALL.
SCHOOL ABSENTEEISM AND SCHOOL
TROOP AND CITY AND THAT IT'S
SOMETHING THAT I READ ARE
TRUANCY IN ATTENDANCE YET NOT
VERY CLOSE WITH ORAL EIGHT
SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN OUR COUNTY
INCLUDING FREMONT IF I'D.
ON THAT TOPIC.
BUT I WANTED TO DISCUSS BRIEFLY.
AS ARE LOST TO REFUND IT
BULLYING.
AND FACT AT THE CALIFORNIA PEACE
CODE ACTUALLY DOESN'T DEFINE
BULL BEING AS A CRIME.
DOESN'T DEFINE BULLYING AT ALL
WE COULD NOT GO INTO A COURT
ROOM WHICH THE PERSON CHART WITH
THAT I'M OF ITS EGGS.
AND I THINK THAT WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THIS IN WORK.
IN THE IF IT'S IMPORTANT TO KNOW
HOW WHAT GOALS WE HAVE THE
ENGINE COURTROOM --
SUPPORT BOTH THE VICTIM AND HOLD
THE PERPETRATOR COUNSEL.
FOR BULLYING CONDUCT --
THERE ABOUT THERE ARE FOUR MAJOR
PEOPLE CODE SECTIONS THAT WERE
HE TURNS TO ONE IS OKAY ACTION.
SIX FIFTY THREE IT'S A PERCENT
USING ELECTRONIC RIGHT.
MAKES REPEATED --
ROUSING --
CONSTITUTE ANOTHER WHEN WE
THIRDS MAJORS IN KIDS WITH THE
NONSTOP PHONE CALLING IN HERE
YEP I'M CALLING IT.
AND MAKING IN ARE THREATENING
COMMENTS THAT OUT COURSE
EXPANDED TO ANY MEANS OF
ELECTRONIC COMMUNICATION WHICH
IS FRONT AND CENTER
CYBERBULLYING.
I'M PENAL CODE SECTION FOUR
TWENTY TWO ARE IS BASICALLY
COVERING THREAT.
AND THAT IS A PERSON AND
THREATENS TO KILL OR PHYSICALLY
HARM SOMEBODY.
AT EPCOT THREAT IS TAKEN
SERIOUSLY IMPACT IS BELIEVED AND
IT IS A QUICK CALL AN IMMEDIATE.
THE LAW WAS CHANGED W. IS BACK
TO INCLUDE.
THAT THAT RECORD DONE.
WRITING VERBALLY OR TRYING TO
INDICATE AN INNING [INAUDIBLE]
LABOR THREATS.
THERE IS NO CODE SECTION
PROHIBITS THE PRECIPITATION OF
ANOTHER ONLINE SO IF FOR EXAMPLE
I THINK THIS HAPPENS OFTEN IN
SCHOOLS FOR A STUDENT WILL THE
LIBRARY.
DOING WORK FINANCING OR HER --
MAIL ADDRESS AT FORGET TO SIGN
OUT LEAVE INSTANTLY YOUR DOG AND
STUFF IF YOU'RE OPEN ANOTHER
STUDENT WILL COME SIT DOWN AT
THE COMPUTER TERMINAL.
REALIZE HERE SHE CAN TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THE PORTABLE AND
THAT AND AND HARASSES.
THE PERSON EIGHT IN THE
INDIVIDUAL THAT THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE SEEING MORE
AND MORE PART TAKE PLACE.
A SCHOOL SETTINGS AND THE FINAL
PENAL CODE SECTION THAT WAS
REALLY THAT SOMETHING WE REALLY
REAL.
CYBER STALKING.
THOUGH.
SHOULD ONLY I'VE BEEN IN THE D.
IS OFFICE FOR TWENTY SEVEN YEAR
IN MY FIRST TEN YEARS IN THE
OFFICE OF OUT OF STOCK IN CASE.
IT WAS WHAT WE TRADITIONALLY
THINK OF SOMEBODY WAS CONSTANTLY
GOING UP BUT SOMEONE HOUSE
FOLLOW THEM TO BURKE.
FOLLOWING THEM AROUND SCHOOL AND
CREATING FEAR THAT WAY AND THE
CYBER STALKING STATUTE --
INCORPORATES THAT NONSTOP.
ALWAYS.
BUT VIA AN ONLINE [INAUDIBLE]
PLATFORM AND FLYING AS THE IN
PERSONS GETTING.
MY COLLEAGUE HERE AND I ARE
GOING TO SHARE OUR MINUTES EACH
AND MINE IT WILL BE A FULL
FOURTEEN THAT'S TO BE LITTLE
MORE DYNAMIC FOR YOU SO I'M
GONNA TURN OVER.
TO MY LEAGUE FROM THIS COUNTY
YEAH TALK A LITTLE BIT MORE
ABOUT ASSEMBLY I SURE.
AND THANK YOU AGAIN FOR HAVING
AT FIRST I WANT TO SAY THAT.
WE'RE REALLY LUCKY IN SANTA
CLARA COUNTY AT OUR BORDERS
SUPERVISORS TO ORDER THE DA'S
OFFICE TO HAVE COMMUNITY
PROSECUTORS TO DO READ.
IN THE COMMUNITY ON ALL SORTS OF
ISSUES.
INCLUDING POURING AND HE I'M SO
FOR EXAMPLE.
LAST YEAR ONE OF OUR COMMUNITY
PROSECUTOR ORGANIZED A
CONFERENCE AT GOOGLE HAVE A
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN TECHNOLOGY
COMPANIES.
SCHOOL.
AND LAW ENFORCEMENT TO ADDRESS
HOW WE CAN WORK TOGETHER.
MOST USERS ARE IN THE SCHOOL.
NOT JUST.
TWO ABOUT WHEN THE PRIME BUT
WHEN THERE'S A BULLYING AND
HARASSMENT DOESN'T RISE TO THE
LEVEL OF CRIME.
BUT IT'S STILL VERY HURTFUL BOTH
TO THE INDIVIDUAL.
TARGETED INTO THE SCHOOL
COMMUNITY THE BAD HOW WE CAN
ADDRESS.
WHEN THAT HAPPENS FOR THOSE
PERPETRATOR BUT ALSO HOW WE CAN
ADDRESS YOU?
IN THE WHOLE SCHOOL COMMUNITY
AND I THREW HIS LAST YEAR AT OF
THE MIND HIGH SCHOOL IN PLENTY
OF NOT ONLY WAS THERE A SERIES
OF INCIDENTS INVOLVING.
REYES ALL AND JUST HARASSMENT.
THERE WAS AN INTERVIEW DID NOT
ONLY DEALT WITH THE PERPETRATOR
TO THAT PROCESS AND AND TRY TO
HELP THE VICTIMS OF THAT PROCESS
AND REALLY FOR THE WHOLE SCHOOL
COMMUNITY TO HAVE.
PAST THAT AND I THINK THAT'S THE
NETS IMPORTANT FOR US.
TO FIND IT THINK ABOUT.
AS FAR AS WE'RE BOTH BEING AND
HATE CRIME.
INTER STACK DON'T REMOTE IN THE
BLACK COMMITTEE MEMBERS IDEA
ABOUT AN INCIDENT.
THAT HAPPENED IN OUR COMMUNITY A
COUPLE YEARS AGO BUT SAN JOSE
STATE THERE WAS A SUBJECT OF
BEGINNING BORING BUT AT THE END
OF HATE CRIMES.
AND BY HIS TWEET MATES USE AN
AFRICAN AMERICAN STUDENT.
AND M..
YEAH AND HE WAS PUT IN A BIKE
LOCK.
RIGHT WITH ME.
BUT BEFORE THEN.
AS DISPLAYS SWASTIKA IN THEIR
DORM ROOM SUITE THERE WAS THE
CONF READ FULL BAG THAT PRESENT
USE OF A VERSION OF THE N. WORD.
IT WAS REFERRING TO AN S. THREE
FIFTHS WHICH IS A REFERENCE.
TO THE U. S. CONSTITUTION THAT
REFERRED TO AFRICAN AMERICAN
HISTORY.
OF A PERSON IN THE REGION.
DOCUMENTATION.
SOMEONE THE HIGHLIGHT ALL OF YOU
BUT THAT WAS THE END OF THAT
CASE WHERE THE JURY.
FOUND THESE.
THREE THE FACT IS GUILTY OF
CRIMES BUT DIDN'T FIND THEM
GUILTY OF HATE CRIMES.
AND THE REASON WHY I WANNA
HIGHLIGHT THAT.
IS BECAUSE WE TALK ABOUT.
IMPLICIT BIAS NOT COMPLETED THIS
LOSING THE BATTLE ACT LISTED BY
S..
THERE REALLY WAS A CHALLENGE FOR
THE MEMBERS OF THE JURY. TO
LABEL.
YOUNG WHITE COLLEGE STUDENTS AS
ASSIST.
YOU WITH THEIR DECISION.
GOING TO BE DOING.
AND THAT MADE IT I THINK AN
EXTRA BURDEN TO OVERCOME AND TO
WHAT WAS VERY BRAVE FOR THIS.
JURY THAT WHAT WE VIEW AS A SIN
VERY EXPLICIT.
A RACIALLY MOTIVATED AND
INCIDENTS AND ALSO IN IT ACT.
AS MORE THAN JUST AN ATTACK AT A
CRIME.
DAHLE MINIATURE ACT BY A
COLLEAGUE IN WILL KEEP UP
TEXTING IT.
ADDITIONS TO IN OUR HATE CRIMES.
THAT ARE.
UP REYES FAITH OR RELIGION.
PROP UP IN OUR SCHOOL OF COURSE
RECEIPT.
OF CYBERBULLYING AT THAT
VENTURES AROUND --
SPECIAL.
EXCEPT AS SEXTING AND SEX GENDER
BASED -- ONE
THING THAT WE HAVE FOUND SO
IMPORTANT IS TO GO OF COURSE.
EDUCATION IS AGE APPROPRIATE AND
START TALKING ARM AT THAT TIME.
ABOUT.
THE INJURY THAT K. POP UP FROM
IN -- TO IT
WITHIN EITHER DOUBLE OR GIRL'S
IN TERMS OF WHAT IS BEING LISTED.
ONLINE AND THAT WHAT WE WHAT
TROUBLE THEY GET INTO BOTH.
MOST ONLY SO BILLY AS WELL AS
THE VEHICLE DISCIPLINED AND
MAYBE IN THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM OF IF OFF.
THE ENGAGED IN.
AND REBEL BEING IN THIS --
EIGHT IN IT BILL ALSO I HEARD
SOMEBODY MENTION --
HUMAN TRAFFICKING IS IT TO THE
ARENA TO WITH I'M SORRY LEAGUE
SPLIT AND MINE.
AND WE FIND THAT OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE IF THE GREATER NOT TOO
YOUNG.
TO JOIN THE CONVERSATION.
AND THE STUDENT.
PROGRESS IN SCHOOL THAT.
MIDDLE SCHOOL AND THEN AGAIN IN
HIGH SCHOOL IT'S COOL COLD BUT
WE AS EXPLICIT AND MEANINGFUL
CONVERSATION.
AT AT ONE THING THAT I AM TOLD.
BY THE STUDENTS THAT I WORK WITH
IS THAT.
HE'S.
ASSEMBLY'S OR JUST AT OR
INFORMATIONAL THOUGHT AS WORK
MUCH BETTER WHEN THEY ARE LED BY
STUDENTS THEMSELVES.
UP AND I THINK THAT SOMETHING HE
FOR US ALL TO REMEMBER THAT
OFTENTIMES THEY DON'T WANT FROM
US THEY WANT TO HEAR FROM THEIR
PEAK -- IS.
THOUGH --
TRAINING AND THEN HERE TO APPEAR.
IN ACTION AND IT.
REALLY REALLY STRONG.
YOUR WERE RUNNING OUT OF TIME
APPOINTED DRAFT AN ASPECT OF
BULLET BEING ON CAMPUS.
THAT WE HAVEN'T TALKED ABOUT YET.
EDUCATION CODE ALLOWS SCHOOL
SCHOOL DISTRICT TO DISCIPLINE
STUDENTS ARE TO TAKE OTHER KINDS
OF INTERVENTIONS WHEN THERE'S
BLINKING ON CAMPUS AND I THINK
IT'S NINE CENTER.
WE NOT UNDERSTOOD ENOUGH.
THAT EXTENDS OUT.
THERE INVOLVED MEMBER SCHOOL
COMMUNITY.
OFF CAMPUS OR NOT WITHIN THE
SCHOOL ORDERS SO IF YOU HAVE AN
INCIDENT WHERE.
SCHOOL STUDENTS FOR EXAMPLE.
ARE TEXT NEW CHAIR WITH IT GROUP
OR ARE.
SCHOOL ALL THE PEOPLE ARE MOST
OF THE PEOPLE ARE PART OF THE
SCHOOL COMMUNITY THIS DOES NOT
HAVE TO SAY WOW THAT DOESN'T
INVOLVE US BACK ACTUALLY VERY
MUCH IT DOES INVOLVE.
US IN THE SCHOOL IS.
THE BEST PLACE I THINK.
TO WORK ON COMMUNITY PROBLEMS IS
THE COMMUNITY THAT'S BEING
TARRED.
IS PART OF THAT SCHOOL UNITY AND
WE AND ARE TRINITY PROSECUTOR
FOR THE D. TOP TERROR HERE TO
PARTNER WITH OUR LOCAL SCHOOLS
TO HELP YOU TO FIGURE OUT.
IS A VIOLATION OF THE CALIFORNIA
EDUCATION CODE ALSO WHAT KIND OF
INTERVENTIONS THAT ARE SO.
WHAT I HAD THERE ARE IS
SOMETHING THAT STUDENTS CAN BUY
INTO A CAN HERE COMMUNITY WE CAN
WORK ON TOGETHER?
EDIT EDITION TO WORKING WITH THE
STUDENTS IT ALSO VITAL BUT
PROGRAMMING IS AS TARGETED
TOWARD THE PARENTS.
OF STUDENTS WHO ARE FULLY EIGHT
AS WELL AS ARMS OF THE STUDENTS
WHO ARE BULLYING STUDIES SHOW
THAT.
THIS THE KIDS DO NOT FALL INTO
ONE CATEGORY OR THE OTHER
OFTENTIMES.
SINCE.
HE WAS LEAD.
CAN ALSO BECOME WILL LEAD OR
VICE VERSA AND WHAT.
AN POINT THAT I THINK IS
CRITICAL TO TAKE WAY FOR DOESN'T
MAKE SENSE THE CHILD --
JUST GO ONLINE BECAUSE IT'S NOT
REAL STUCK AND IT SEEMS SO.
EASY JUST DON'T LOOK YOUR
INSTAGRAM ACCOUNT OR DO TURN ON
YOUR COMPUTER AND THAT IS NOT
THE RIGHT ANSWER.
AND THEN THE OTHER IS NOT
WRITTEN TO TAKE AWAY --
THAT DEVICE AS A AN ISSUE
BECAUSE THAT JUST DRIVES
VICTIMIZATION AND THEIR GROUND
AND O'DONNELL TO WHERE YOUNG
PEOPLE ARE YOU THAT AFRAID. TO
COME OUT AND TELL A TEACHER OR
TALK. FOR FEAR OF HAVING THEIR
DEBATES TAKEN FROM THAT WHICH IS
REALLY.
HOUSE WITH A LIFELINE AND WAY OF
PLANNER ACTION THAT IS THE NORM
RATHER THAN.
THEN NOT BOUGHT.
EIGHT BELIEVE THAT WE READ
THROUGH OUR FOURTEEN MINUTES
EARTH THAT WENT BACK.
TO YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SURE THAT THE PERSON AND AND
INFORMATION.
YOU MENTIONED ABOUT HOW --
THE INFORMATION PROVIDED THROUGH
THE PARENTS IS SAID ONLINE OR IS
THE SOMEWHERE THAT WOULD BE ABLE
TO HELP YOU GET THE WORDS OUT.
ALAMEDA COUNTY WITH YOU GO
REGULARLY INTO THE SCHOOLS AND
WE HAVE PRESENTED IN THAT IT FOR
THE STUDENT WE WILL.
WE ARE ON CALL COME IN AND GIVE
REASONS EIGHT IS AT A HAVE A
POWER POINT THAT WE HAVE THE
DATE.
I AM SO IN THE OFFICE THAT WHEN
I WE'RE STILL TALKING ABOUT
MYSPACE.
NO NOBODY DOES THAT IS MARK BUT
WE DO TRY TO KEEP IT --
AND I WISH THAT THE THE YOU KNOW
THE REASONS AND THAT WE HAVE --
TOGETHER AND I ALWAYS WELL.
YEAH SORT OF BEING THE COMMUNITY
KNOW THAT.
WOULD BE IT.
WILL COME ANY --
THAT WERE ASKED TO COME THAT A
GROUP FEELS.
WOULD BE OF HELP. TO YOU SO
YOU'LL BE ABLE TO PUT A LINE.
OF PEOPLE OF* STILL. ZERO
ONE OF MY FROM FOR ME AS A AS
THE THE PEOPLE OF COLOR YOU KNOW
I WAS ALWAYS WONDERING.
SHOULD I VERY INTERESTED ON WHAT
YOU'RE OUT THERE FOR THE PARENTS.
AND SONS --
LOOKS LIKE A OUR STATE WE HAVE
SOME WORK TO HELP US.
ROUTE FINE MAY BE.
THE DEFINITION OF HATE CRIMES SO
WE'LL BE ABLE TO MAKE THAT THE
AGE OF TO HAVE THOSE HUNGER KATE.
WHO WAS STRAPPED YOU HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS ON THE?
I THANK YOU.
WITH KANSEN AND IT'S GREAT TO
HEAR FROM IS MEGHAN AND MISTER
GIVE IS OF COURSE THOSE ARE NOT
ALWAYS ADOPTED.
FROM HERE TO THE CHANCE --
TO TO TO KNOW JAMES WELL AS AS A
VERY ETHICAL AND RESPONSIBLE THE
PROSECUTOR AND IT'S GREAT TO
HEAR THE WORK --
THANKS TO THE COUNTY AS WELL
JUST CONTAINS OFFICE OF THE
COMMITTEE PROSECUTORS I GOT THE
CHANCE TO KNOW A LOT OF THEM
OVER THE YEARS TO THINGS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT.
PROGRAM --
THAT WE HAVE AND AND YOU KNOW
WHEN I THINK ABOUT PROSECUTION
THERE ARE TWO SIDES.
TO THE NEED TO HAVE
SOPHISTICATION AT THE THE
VICTORIA LEVEL.
ENGINES UNDERSTANDING THE
COMMITTEE IN UNDERSTANDING --
HATE CRIMES ESPECIALLY AS THE
POWERS TO WHAT WE'VE BEEN SEEING
MORE RECENTLY SURE.
THE PROCESSING THESE CRIMES AS
HATE CRIMES BUT ALSO I'M THE
DEFENSE PERSPECTIVE SOMETIMES
THE RESPONSE FROM SOMEONE IS
BEING BULLIED VICTIMIZED AT A
RESPOND BACK IN UNDERSTANDING.
THE CONTEXT OF THAT IT THERE
MUST AMERICAN OR A SICK AMERICAN
OR ODD LGBTQ AND THEY'RE BEING
BULLIED --
IN A VARIETY OF WAYS INCLUDING
ELECTRONICALLY AND AND THEY
RESPOND BACK AND THEY'RE THE
ONES THAT YOU ASK.
CHANNING DIG DIG DEEPER ON THE
CONTEXT OF EXACTLY WHAT'S GOING
ON IN THAT SCHOOL OR IN THAT
COMMUNITY OR IN THAT
NEIGHBORHOOD.
AND I THINK HAS PARTICULARLY
SINCE WE'VE --
SIAN AND IN THE LAST COUPLE
YEARS A PARTICULAR --
INCREASED NUMBER HE CRIES WITH
AFTER BECAUSE LATIN AMERICANS IN
A COMMITTEE CAN OF COURSE --
OVER SEVERAL YEARS --
AND EVEN THOUGH I THINK WE'VE
SEEN AN INCREASED LEVEL OF
INTENSITY AGAINST SOME AMERICANS
A CERTAINLY WITH THE SOUTH ASIAN.
OF THE COMMUNITY --
ELDERLY AMERICANS ARE GETTING
BEATEN IT AND IT IS JUST.
A HORRIBLE --
BUT A FEW YEARS.
BUT WHAT'S WORSE ISN'T FROM
OTHER COUNTIES ARE THE DATES.
YET PROSCAR IS EIGHT TIMES A
LIST -- WE
HAVE PROSPECTORS ARE LEAST.
IDENTIFY IT AS CRIES THE ISSUE
MIGHT BE WITH THE DURING HIS OR
WITH HOW YOU ACTUALLY ARE ABLE
TO PROVE IT AND THAT'S AND MET.
CANS MAKES A GOOD POINT ABOUT
MAKING SURE THAT THE THE FRANKLY
NOT LET THAT THE GROUND LEVEL I
DO KNOW FOR EXAMPLE SAUDI PLEASE
PART AND WHEN THEY'RE GOING
THROUGH --
THE ACADEMY THEY THEY MEET WITH
MUSCLE AMERICAN LEADERS TO GO TO
THE THE THE GOOD WATER AND AND
MEET WITH THE SICK AMERICAN
COMMUNITY TO UNDERSTAND THE ANY
BETTER --
AND I KNOW WE'VE COMMITTEE
PROSECUTORS ENTRANCE OF ONLINE
PROSECUTORS ARE MAKING THE
CHARGES ISSUES THAT ARE
PROCESSING THE CASE AS TO WHAT
EXTENT HAVE FALLEN AND EITHER
COUNTY.
ON THE ACTUALLY GOING TO EITHER
TRAINING OR INTERACTING WITH THE
COMMUNITY OUTSIDE AGAIN OF THE
PROSECUTORS ARE PROCESS OR ANY
PROSECUTOR.
OSCARS BRING FOLKS TO BRING
INFORMATION TO THEM SO.
JUST CURIOUS AS TO WHAT'S GOING
ON ON THE GROUND LEVEL LESSER
FIRST SAY THAT.
I THINK THE WEEK AND DO BETTER
SANTA CORRECTLY IS INCREDIBLY
DIVERSE COMMUNITY.
AT LANGUAGES OUR MORE THAN WE
CAN COUNT MORE THAN THE PEOPLE
ROOM OR THE NUMBER OF LANGUAGES
LOOKING IT'S A CLARA COUNTY.
IT'S A CONSTITUENT CHALLENGE TO
MAKE SURE THAT WERE SENT TO ALL
THE DIFFERENT.
KINDS OF GROUPS WITHIN COUNTY.
HE CRIED INPUT --
ONE PHASE WE TRIED TO DEAL WITH
IT IN ANY CASE THAT HAS ANY PART
THAT MIGHT RELATE TO A HATE
CRIME.
THAT WAS TO ACTUALLY AT THAT I
SUPERVISE.
SET WERE MAKING SURE THAT THE
PEOPLE.
IN THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE
EIGHT UP ON ALL THE CRAP LAW.
INSPECTORS AND I ARE OF A
WITNESS OFF WE ALL --
HOW?
ARE.
HAVE BIAS TRAINING ON A REGULAR
BASIS AS A SET BY A STREAKING WE
ALSO DO YOU HAVE AS YOU KNOW IT
THAT SPECIALIZE.
IN HATE I AM AND AS MENTIONED
EARLIER WE ARE SET YEARS BACK A
LIST OF ALL IN HOTLINE.
AT WE ARE.
AT THE HEARING SANTA CLARA CAN
WE START MORE WORK WIDGET THAT
CAN THEY CAN BE PLANTED IN
ALAMEDA COUNTY.
AND THEY ARE VERY --
CONSCIENTIOUS ABOUT MAKING SURE
THAT WE HAVE OUR OWN.
PEOPLE WHO CAN WORK IT IN
VARIOUS LANGUAGES WITH THOSE WHO
CALL IN.
THEY MAY NOT NECESSARILY BE UP
THE COMPLAINANT MAY NOT A SISTER
RIGHT THE LEVEL OF A CRIME.
BUT THAT DOESN'T MEAN THAT WE
SHOULDN'T SITTING ON A TENSION
APPELLEE FOCUSED.
ON HOW.
THE MATTER CAN BE A BEST.
I DON'T BELIEVE THE COURT.
AND PROSECUTION NECESSARILY THE
RIGHT. FOR EVERY INCIDENT.
INVOLVES JUVENILES OR ADULTS
ESPECIALLY IN THE JUVENILE
SETTING.
AT TIMES THERE CAN BE A MORE
REALISTIC IT --
WAY TO WHICH THE SITUATION THAT.
YOUR EVERYBODY NOT JUST THE
PERSON WHO'S BEING BULLIED BUT
AS YOU SAID.
THE PERSON HIS ACTUALLY MAYBE.
TAKING THE CHECKS AND GOING TO
THE BILL ARE GOING TO THE CENTER
OF THE AFTER MAKE ME CENTERS AND
YOU GET TO THAT UPDATE I KNOW
HOW BUSY EVERYBODY IS.
THE MAYBE YOU KNOW OF A ONCE
EVERY SIX MONTHS --
ONCE A QUARTER ADDED SOME
SPECIAL TYPE OF VIBE VISIT JUST
TO GET THEM THE COMMUNITY
BECAUSE I THINK I MAY SECURITY
PEOPLE.
I'M A LOT MORE COMFORTABLE BUT
OTHERWISE I DO APPRECIATE
SENSITIVITY TO WORK THAT YOU
HAVE DOINGS THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANKS TO ASSEMBLYMEMBER CAR.
SEARCH VITA COMMITTEE SEE
[INAUDIBLE]
I JUST.
IN TWO SEPARATE YOU BRING.
SOME OF THE GROUND BUT THAT WE
TALKED ABOUT IN OUR OPENING
COMMENTS THANK YOU FOR THE DO A
RIGHT TO CHÁVEZ.
PRESS ALL RIGHT GREAT.
EACH OWN WHAT WERE.
THE TO BRING THIS TAKEN.
US UP ON THE DAY AREAS.
BUT BEFORE I DO THAT WATER
RECOGNIZED --
SENATOR FROM SENATOR JIM BELL'S
OFFICE JONAS AND SS.
AND ALSO I'M
.
OUR BOOK CAN WE GO BACK TO THE
ACTUAL BILL.
WHAT'S OTHER NAMES ON THE
PANELISTS NAME.
WHO WHO WHO'S CONTROLLING THEIR
AGO OKAY SO DO PAULA THROUGH WAS
ASKED TO OF?
THOSE I DON'T KNOW IF.
ANY PROTECT THE ALL DAY YOU HAVE
WORK -- I
THINK WE'RE SETTING THE ORDER
THAT WE'RE GONNA SPEECH AND
SITTING ON THE ORDER OKAY SO
AWARE OF ROAD JUST --
HI MARKS. FOR SPEAKER.
SO I WANTED TO BEGIN BY THANKING
EVERYONE FOR HOLDING --
THIS SADDAM THIS HEARING AND
ESPECIALLY THANKED THEM ALL FOR
DOING AN INCREDIBLE JOB IN
ORGANIZING US --
YOU KNOW A THAT A LOT OF
DEALINGS WITH HER AT NIGHT.
WHEN I LOOK AT THE NUMBER THAT
ARE SPEAKING ON THE PANEL?
AND OTHER PANELS AS WELL I'M
SURE THAT IT WAS A HUGE F. SO I
WANT TO THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
OF TOPICS AND ONE IS TRENDS AND
ANOTHER --
ON OF OF PREVENTION OR WHERE OR
HOW DO WE HOW TO ADDRESS THESE
ISSUES I'M SPEAKING.
ON THE AMERICAN LOOK BLOOM ALL
POPULATION I WANT TO BEGIN BY
TALKING ABOUT FRIENDS BY TALK
FIRST ABOUT THE POLITICAL
ENVIRONMENT THAT MOST AMERICANS
FIND SELVES AND IF YOU THE EDGE
OF THE POOL PLAYER OUT THERE ON
AMERICAN PUBLIC SENTIMENT
TOWARDS MUSLIMS.
OUT OF IT.
IT'S GONE FROM TO WORKS --
QUITE FRANKLY AND WHAT WE KNOW
THAT THE NUMBERS ARE TRUE
BECAUSE THE ROLE IN AS A AS HUBS
DID THE ISSUE AT THE OLD
REINFORCE EACH OTHER --
THAT THE WHAT THE ONES THAT I
WANT TO MENTION AT THE ONE TWO
THOUSAND AND SEVEN IN PUPIL WHEN
THEY LOOK TO AND ASKED AMERICANS
ABOUT THEIR SENTENCE STORE
DIFFERENT.
OF RELIGIOUS GROUPS MUSLIMS DID
FORTUNATELY.
WORST -- AND
SOME OF THE VIEWS THAT RESONATES
WITH AMERICAN VALUES OF OR YOU
CAN SEE ARE PROBABLY NEGATIVE ON
THE SENATE THIS.
RES PATIENT TO YOU AS YOU KNOW
AS FAR AS PART OF THE TESTIMONY.
OFF THE GOOD NEWS IS THAT NOTING
A PERSON WHO IS A MUSLIM TENSED
IMPROVED PERCEPTION IS ABOUT
THEM AND THAT'S DOUBLY IMPORTANT
TO OUGHT TO KNOW.
SOURCE TO THE NEGATIVE
PERCEPTIONS I WOULD SAY
ISLAMOPHOBIA PROBABLY OF IS ON
THE TOP THE LIST ISLAMOPHOBIA IS
THE IRRATIONAL FEAR THAT THE
AMERICANS.
HAVE OF OF OF MUSLIMS OF AND
IT'S NOT JUST HOPPING A NEGATIVE
PERCEPTIONS.
ON A FOUR BILLS NOW HAS BECOME
AN INDUSTRY.
IS A HAVE A FUNDED.
OVER A HUNDRED BILLION OVER THE
LAST TEN YEARS HEAVILY FUNDED TO
IF YOU HAVE A HANDFUL OF A
VISUALS.
ARE PRODUCING VITRIOLIC
INFORMATION ABOUT MUSLIMS IN A
SMALL.
IS BEING PUT OUT ON ON NEWS
CHANNELS IS BEING PUT OUT
THROUGH A POLITICIAN'S THROUGH
PUNDITS.
THROUGH BOOKS THAT ARE BEING
WRITTEN ABOUT MUSCLE.
AND I THINK THAT THAT'S PROBABLY
THE THE BIGGEST SOURCE OF
ISLAMOPHOBIA.
IRRATIONAL FEAR THAT MANY
AMERICANS HAVE IMMIGRATION
RESULT AS YOU MIGHT IMAGINE IS
OF COURSE HARASSMENT AND
BULLYING OF MY CHILDREN.
IN THE COUNCIL ON AMERICAN
ISLAMIC RELATIONS A STUDY --
AND DO IT EVERY YEAR AND IT
SHOWED THAT CLEARLY THAT OF THAT
SOME AMERICAN STUDENTS --
EXPERIENCE OF OF BULLY
EXTENSIVELY ONE OUT OF TWO OF
MUSLIMS IN CHILDREN AND THIS
BUILDING IN SCHOOLS IN.
HARASSMENT ENTITIES OR IN --
IN SOME FORM AND IT'S AND WORSE
UP SINCE THE LAST PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTION.
ANOTHER UP AND THAT'S WHEN
CONSEQUENCE OF THE POLITICAL AND
WHEN IT IS A FEELING ASHAMED AND
CURRENT EVENT DISCUSSIONS.
UP IN WHICH IS WHICH IS GETTING
OUT FIRST THAT WAY THAT THAT
THAT FEATURE FRAME CONVERSATION.
OF IN IN THE FRAME OF US FOR
THAT.
THE MOST ARE USED VIEWED AS THE
ENEMY.
OF DISABILITY LACKING
SENSITIVITY TOWARDS THE FACT
THAT MANY OF THESE KIDS ACT HAVE
RELATIVES OF THE PALM TREES AT
THAT.
ARE THE TEACHERS ARE TALKING
ABOUT.
THEN ALL POINTING TO BUT MOST
KEVIN ASKING THEM TO BE BOMB THE
EXPERTS ON SOD ON THESE ISSUES.
OF THIRD CONSEQUENCE IS JUST.
CONFIRM THAT ABOUT THEIR
IDENTITY.
IT BECOMES EVEN ARE BECOMES EVEN
WORSE.
I DO FOLKS ON THE REMEDIES HOW
YOU DO YOU TURN THIS AROUND TO
FOSTER INCLUSION PREVENT
BULLYING OF SOME SORT.
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT EFFORTS TO
FOCUS ON EFFECT I THINK 8090% OF
OUR APPROACH BE ON THE IN THE
SPACE.
OF THE GATES THE ASSISTANT DA
TALKING ABOUT TREATING THAT THEY
DO AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND CARL
I'LL TALK TO VOTE.
THEM AT THE BASE OF THE SPENDING
WITH THE COMMUNITY IN ADDITION
TO WHAT HE RECOMMENDED I THINK
THAT IT'S ALSO.
GO OUT WITH WHEN THEY DO
TRAINING IN THE SCHOOLS HOW MOST
OR ARAB REPRESENTATIVE OF A SIKH
REPRESENTATIVE --
AFRICAN AMERICAN AND SO FORTH I
WOULD REALLY.
RECOMMEND THAT SCHOOL POLICIES
IT CREDIBLY --
IMPORTANT YOU ALL KNOW WHAT THE
LAWS ARE IN.
THE NEED FOR FORMAL ANTI
BULLYING PROGRAM I WAS TO HEAR
ABOUT GOVERNOR BROWN SIGNS BEING
ON A BILL I THINK IT'S A. B. TWO
TWO NINE ONE DON'T QUOTE ME ON
THAT BURKE --
BETTER THE OTHER PLAYERS THAT AT
THE SEAT EITHER AT THE CULT.
EDUCATION UPPER RIGHT ENTITLING
OUT BEING A TO ALSO PROVIDE
SOURCES.
OF THAT A TEACHER MIGHT MIGHT
USE.
OF THERE ARE MURPHY'S AT THAT
SCHOOL TEACH --
OF MIGHT WORK TO PREVENT
BULLYING WE DO A LOT OF
EDUCATION OR TRAINING AS DO A
LOT OF STUDENTS EDUCATION IN WHY
EDUCATION BECAUSE CREDIT REPORT.
SO I'M SCARED A BUNCH OF SLIDES
AND GO INTO THE IMPORTANCE.
ENHANCING EDUCATOR UNDERSTANDING
OF MOST STUDENT PROGRAMS
ADDRESSING COMMON CONCEPTION.
REASONABLE ACCOMMODATIONS FOR
MUSLIMS A LOT OF A LOT OF THE
SOURCES OF PULLING COMES WITH
THE FACT THEY DON'T SHOW.
UP AT BASIC INFORMATION ABOUT
THIS TOO SAID THEY'RE DEALING
WITH AND THEN HE SORT DOES FOR
EDUCATORS WHICH BUT MY
ORGANIZATION REALLY.
DESPISES THAT.
WE HAVE OF AS SPEAKERS BUREAUS.
HELLO OF FIRST AMENDMENT CENTER
GOT IT LINES THAT HAVE TO DO IT
SWORE TO TALK ABOUT YOU KNOW.
I AM ISLAM HOW TO TALK ABOUT.
THE ISM HINDI EMUS.
WE OF AN ISLAMIC SPEAKERS BUREAU
AND WE DO TO HUNDREDS OF THESE
IN YOUR COUNTY HERE.
AND THROUGHOUT THE BAY AREA WITH
TO HAVE INTERFACE SPEAKERS
BUREAU AS YOU GO OUT WE JEWS
CHRISTIANS.
OR HINDUS AND BUDDHISTS TOGETHER
TO SOLVE MEDICAL KILLAM.
AND WE'LL PROVIDE ONLINE
EDUCATED OF CURRICULUM AND
ANSWERS JUST OVER TWO HUNDRED
FREQUENTLY ASKED QUESTIONS ABOUT
SUMMER SOME SO VERY INVESTED IN
PREVENTION.
AS I THINK THAT RELIGIOUS SPACE.
AND ETHNIC BASED BULLYING IS
PREVENTABLE THROUGH EDUCATION.
THANK YOU GREATER WAS THREE AND
YOU WERE VERY.
YOU'RE.
OPTIMISTIC ABOUT.
IT DID THAT IT IS.
WHO CAN BE PREVENT THAT SO
THAT'S GREAT --
LOWELL.
LOVE TO HAVE YOUR SLIGHT UNTIL
WE MAY BE ABLE TO INCLUDED AND
ON MY WEBSITE.
OR SOMETHING GRAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
THEREFORE HAVE DIANE.
M. FISHER EACH DAY THANK YOU FOR
INCLUDING ME TOO AND PROBABLY
NOT MUCH TO YOUR SURPRISE.
SO JUST ONE ADDRESS THE
ATMOSPHERE FOR STARTERS OF WHAT
OUR KIDS ARE LIVING IN.
ON THIS LAST WEEK WE SIDE
SEVERAL EXAMPLES OF OVERT
ANTISEMITISM THE PUBLIC'S TO
THOSE OF US WORKING.
OUR DEMOCRACY.
HE ACCUSED GEORGE SOROS OF
PAYING THE COVEN OF PROTESTERS
AND I'D ROUTE JULIE ANNE CALLING
STRESS ANTI CHRIST.
SO THIS IS AN ATTEMPT TO PULL
THE REASON PROTESTERS IS ME
PONDS ORCHESTRATED BY A SINGLE
JUST PUSH PERSON.
THEN WE HAD WHITE NATIONALIST
TRIBUTE FLYERS AT UC DAVIS UC
BERKELEY.
AT BLAMED USE FOR ORCHESTRATING
ALLEGATIONS AND CABIN ON THE
FLYERS AND EVERY TIME THEM TO
WHAT EIGHTEEN ANTI AMERICAN ANTI
AMERICAN TAKES PLACE LOOK AT IT.
AND IT'S CHOOSE.
NINE SO UNFORTUNATELY HOUSE WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION AND GROUPS
LIKE THE DAILY STORMER THAT ARE
USED AGE OLD STICK TYPES OF JEWS
BEING.
OUTSIDE AGITATORS --
IN THIS IS NOT ONLY HOPE. TO THE
DUTY COMMUNITY ON THIS IS
HURTFUL TO ALL THE GROUPS THIS
PANEL AND IT'S HURTFUL THAT
ANYONE WORKING FOR SOCIAL CHANGE
RIGHT BECAUSE IT'S A STRATEGY IS
A STRATEGY THAT'S TO DIVIDE US.
TO YOU THE ANTI SEMITISM AS A
TOOL AGAINST PROGRESSIVE IDEAS.
FROM IT SEEKS TO ESTABLISH AN
ASSUMPTION THAT.
AMERICANS HERE TOGETHER CAN
REJECT HIS CONSPIRACY THEORY AND
WE CAN WORK TOGETHER. TO ASSERT
OUR POINT.
OF THE PUBLIC SQUARE AND THIS IS
WHAT I REALLY WANT TO GET SET TO
WHAT AND SHE DID BECAUSE PUT OUT
AN AUTUMN AND MUCH.
SHE HATED STATEMENT CAN DO BEING
THAT ANTI SEMITIC FLYERS
ACTIVIST IN BERKELEY AND IT
SHOWS THAT WE WILL BE DIVIDED
AMONGST OURSELVES [INAUDIBLE]
THANKS.
SO WHEN I SEEN IN OUR SCHOOLS
WITH RESPECT TO ANTI SEMITISM
WEAPONS SCENE IS NAY EAT KIDS.
UP ON THESE OR ANTI SEMITIC
STATE TYPE FROM THE PUBLIC
ENVIRONMENT.
I SAY THAT BECAUSE I ALSO HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO MEET WITH THE
PARENTS OF SOME OF THESE KIDS
WHO'VE BEEN PERPETRATORS.
THEY'VE CLEARLY TRIED TO RAISE
THEIR KIDS WITH.
THESE APPS BUT FOR ALL PEOPLE
AND THE POOR IF THE WORK WITH
THEIR KIDS ARE BIG ENOUGH AND
HOW THEY ARE EXPERTS IN THIS
THESE HOSTILITIES.
THAT'S WHY THIS PUBLIC
CONVERSATION SEVEN PORTENT ON
BECAUSE WE TO NOT ONLY WORK
TOGETHER BUT WE WANT TO SEE THE
PUBLIC.
SEEING US WORK OUT THERE AND SEE
WHAT KIDS CAN PICK UP ON A
DIFFERENT NARRATIVE.
THE MOST RECENT --
INTO SUBMIT STUDENT INCIDENT
THAT I'VE WHERE OF AS LS GET AS
HIGH SCHOOL YOU MAKE THE CALL --
LESTER LOOKS GET AS I PUT IN A
NEW PROGRAM A CONTRACTED THROUGH
EDUCATION WHICH WAS RESPONSE TO
SOME RACES PROM POSE RULES FROM
THE YEAR BEFORE.
AN EPIC EDUCATION TEACHES
STUDENTS INTERN IN REPAIR R. I.
R.. FOR RECOGNIZE INTERRUPTING
AND PAIRING MICRO SESSION THAT
HAPPENED RIGHT AND THIS IS A
REAL HARD FOR STUDENTS TO DO
IT'S HARD FOR IT ADULTS DO --
THEY WORKED ON THE LINE AND THEN
A GROUP OF STUDENTS AND PUT
TOGETHER MISSION STATE ABOUT
SCHOOL STATING.
QUOTE FROM IT ALL STUDENTS WILL
CONFRONT ALL DISCRIMINATE BEEN
OR DISCRIMINATORY SPEECH WILL
TREAT OTHERS WITH COMPASSION AND
STATE THAT FOR PEERS YOU MAY BE
EXPERIENCING DISCRIMINATION.
WILL HAVE TO INCLUDE THE
COMMUNITY AT LARGE JOIN US AT
THE PORT OF THIS AND AND SO I
THEIR MISSION STATEMENT AND
MODIFIED IT CAN REALLY MAKE A
STATEMENT IN A POST.
AT THE JCC WHERE I WORK AND I
GOT CHURCHES IN THE TOWN MEDIUM
AND MANY PEOPLE AROUND.
THE PUBLIC THAT AS A PLEDGE THAT
KIDS NINE RATE AND THIS YEAR THE
SCHOOL THAT POSTER IN EVERY
SINGLE CLASSROOM.
HERE'S THE THING STATEMENT OF
INTENT ENDS.
AS IMPORTANT FIRST RATE WE HONOR
THE ACTUAL PRACTICE OF
INTERRUPTING DISCRIMINATION.
IS A MUCH MORE DIFFICULT AND
MESSY PROPOSITION.
WHEN SCHOOL STARTED THIS YEAR IN
THE CLASSROOM RIGHT UNDERNEATH
IT'S LOVELY POSTER?
AT OTHERWISE DECENT STUDENTS
THERE TO HER SING A JEWISH
STUDENT HE PICKED UP THE OLD
TROPES AND JEWS MANY.
A BUCKET OF COINS IN FRONT
JEWISH STUDENT FACE AND SAID --
YOU PASS THE TEST AND IT KEPT
MESSING POINTS TOWARDS HER AND
HARASSING HER IMPLYING.
WE SLEEP WRONG KIND BASSMAN.
JUST LIKE IT WAS --
DISCRIMINATE THAT THIS DOES IS
HIS PARENTS CAME HERE FROM THE
FORMER SOVIET UNION ESCAPING
RELIGIOUS DISCRIMINATION AND
HERE IN AMERICA SHE WAS
EXPERIENCING THAT.
IT SOME POACHING FOR THE STUDENT.
BREAK UP TO THE FOUR END
REPORTED TO HER ADMINISTRATION
BUT I REALLY WANT TO GIVE KUDOS
TO LET'S GET TIES WITH
MINISTRATION HOW WE RESPONDED
BECAUSE THEY HAVE THESE.
FROM AT EDUCATION INCLUDES SIX
OUR INTERACTIVE ONLINE EDUCATION
PROGRAM THAT EXPLAINS AND SIT
BACK AND IT HAS TO SAY AS FOR
UNDERSTANDING YOUR OWN BIAS.
AND THINKING ABOUT CHANGING THEM
WAS DEAD OF A JUST A NEW
DIRECTION OF KICKING THIS KID
OUT OF THE BILLY SEES THE
TEACHABLE MOMENT --
AND HOPEFULLY MADE A DIFFERENCE
IN THAT STUDENTS THINKING SO.
QUICKLY GIVE TO PROPOSE BILLS TO
PAY FOR OUR COUNTY OR STATE TO
CONSIDER AND WHAT IS THE TO SET
A GOAL FOR EVERY SCHOOL TO HAVE
KIND OF RESTORATIVE JUSTICE
OPPORTUNITY --
IN TO TEACH STUDENTS WHO COMMIT
BOWLING SO OPTION WHERE THEY'RE
YOU KNOW PREACHING TO THE CHOIR
BUT IF WE TARGET OR FUNDS IN OUR
EFFORTS TO REACH.
THOSE KIDS WHO NEED EXTRA THING
I BELIEVE WOULD HAVE A HUGE
IMPACT AND THAT THEY WANT TO
RAISE UP IS A DISCUSSION ABOUT
THE CALIFORNIA HEALTHY KIDS
SURVEY YOU MAY BE FAMILIAR WITH
IT.
A SERVICE.
IS A CONFIDENTIAL SURVEY THAT
SCHOOL AND PERFORM --
ABOUT.
WILL CLIMATE AND SAFETY AND HOW
KIDS FEEL.
JUST THAT GET ON THE BACK IS
PRETTY TEENAGE ASIANS THAT THEY
GET THE MONEY TO DO THIS SURVEY
AND MAYBE SCHOOL DISTRICTS LIKE
LAST WEB GADDIS HAVE ANY.
BUT A LOT OF PLACES DON'T DO
THIS AND WE DON'T HAVE THE DATA
THAT REFLECTS THE PERCEPTION OF
THE STUDENTS A PARTICULAR
STUDENTS OF DIFFERENT RAY TO
ADDRESS THE PROBLEM SO I WITH
FORD HEARING FROM OUR EDUCATORS
ON WHAT THEY THINK IT.
SERVES WHETHER WE CAN IMPLEMENT
MORE BROADLY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CANNOT HELP
A QUIRK.
FROM A CERTAIN COLOR BECAUSE
SOME CLOUT TO SPEAK.
THERE YOU CONSENT.
AFTER EVERYONE IN MIND WAS IN
THEIR BRIEF GORE.
I AM FROM THE CITY COALITION I
AM BASED IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
SICKLE LIST IS A NATIONAL CIVIL
RIGHTS ORGANIZATION THAT WAS
FOUND A FEW MOMENTS AFTER --
NINE ELEVEN AND MUCH OF THE WORK
THAT WE DO IS WE NEED THE BASED
I SURVEYED THE COMMUNITY TO SEE
WHAT WOULD NEED --
AND TO THE TOP AND I DO SEE IS
THAT.
ANY OF OUR KIDS ARE HOT ISSUE IN
SCHOOL.
AND THIS IS BECAUSE OF THEIR
PARENTS.
THEY LOOK A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT
THAN MOST OTHER FOLKS.
A LOT OF OUR US AND OTHERS.
BEEN SPOT THEY WHERE RIBBONS.
AND WHAT TO THE LIST AND IS
VIEWED AS BILL.
AS FOR IT.
AND BECAUSE OF THAT.
YOUNG KIDS ARE HAVING A
DIFFICULT TIME IN SCHOOLS.
I WORKED WITH CAN THE PARTNER
AND WHEN BASED THEIR SCHOOL MADE
WHERE A SMALL LITTLE.
BIT.
IT'LL. EIGHT WHAT'S THAT ON YOUR
WHAT DO YOU WEAR THAT.
NOW THIS FOUR YEAR OLD HAS KNOW
WHY HOW TO ANSWER THIS.
RIGHT -- YOU
KNOW IT'S JUST HERE BUNDLED UP
IN A BALL.
THERE IS SO MUCH PRESSURE PLEASE
YOU KIDS.
DID THIS THE RELIGIOUS THEY'RE
CAUGHT ME.
THEY HAVE NO IDEA WHAT DO.
I'M THERE ARE ALSO RECENT
IMMIGRANTS.
WHEN THERE ARE A?
BUT IS YOUR WOULD WEAR A TURBAN
TO SCHOOL THEY ALSO SAY WHAT'S
THAT RELIGION.
IS ABOUT IT.
AND NOW.
I CURRENTLY WORKING ON THIS TO
MAKE SURE THAT OUR PARENTS ARE
EQUIPPED WITH THE CORRECT
RESOURCES.
IF YOUR CASE IS GOING TO SOME OF
THE BOWLING ISSUE.
OR IS PART OF WOULD YOU POSSIBLY.
ADDRESS DOES IT.
IF YOU ARE YOU KNOW YOU KNOW NOT
ABOUT HOW TO EVEN SPEAK WITH
TEACHER.
VENTURE IN PARENTS ON HOW TO
ADDRESS THESE ISSUES ARE NOT
JUST EDUCATOR BUT WITH A BOLD
WELL. TO ADDRESS THESE ISSUES
WHAT THEY ARE WE NEED.
BOEING HAS BECOME THE TOP THE
TOPIC IN THIS COMMUNITY NOBODY
SPEAKS ABOUT IT.
I HAD TO MAKE SURE THAT --
COMMITTEE FEELS BRAVE ENOUGH. TO
ANSWER THE QUESTION AND SCARE
THE THAT THEY'RE GOING THROUGH.
JUST A MONTH AGO WE TO EARLY AND
IT'S HOT NORTHERN*.
HOW DO?
WE GET THAT.
HOW CAN WE TELL THAT WE NEED TO
START TALKING ABOUT THESE SHOES
AND END UP AT THE CELL?
IN TWENTY TWELVE AND TWENTY
THIRTEEN SURVEY TO FILE.
SUIT AND WE DUCTED IS GOOD WITH
OVER SEVEN HUNDRED STUDENTS AND
I REVIEWED FIFTY SIX STUDENT.
IT FORCE.
THE CALIFORNIA WASHING IN
INDIANA.
WE FOUND BUT JORDY OF SIX
STUDENTS THE OVER 50% SCHOOL
PULLING. TWO THIRDS OR 67% OF
SICK URBAN STUDENTS SHARED THAT
THEY ARE BULLIED IN SCHOOL.
IN FRESNO ALONE SIXTY SEVEN THE
OF URBAN SICK HE TO COMPLAIN
THAT THEY WERE BEING HARASSED
NOT BY.
CLASSMATES BUT ALSO BY THEIR
TEACHERS. 51% OF SIX STUDENTS.
THE SIX YOU BELIEVE THAT SCHOOL
OFFICIALS MOST OF THE TIME ARE.
AT ODDS.
BECAUSE THEIR RELIGIOUS IDENTITY.
THEY LONG HAIR.
I HAVE STILL HERE. EIGHT TIMES A
LITTLE BIT [INAUDIBLE]
SO.
AND FOR THEIR STUDENTS THE C.
GROWING UP.
WE EDUCATE STUDENTS WE DO
AWARENESS PRESENTATION NOT ALL
THE GAR --
IN KINDERGARTEN AND AREAS ALSO
AT SCHOOL BECAUSE WE'VE LEARNED
THAT NOT WHAT THEY DO IT PULLING
STILL OCCURS IN SCHOOLS.
ALSO SEEN ADS --
EDUCATOR GUIDE WILL HELP.
TEACH LEARN IT NOT JUST ABOUT
THEIR RELIGIOUS FAITH SO THERE
SIR.
WHERE THEY COME FROM WHY DID HE
PRACTICE THESE --
THESE BACK USE.
WE'RE STILL PUTTING ITS THE IT'S
IS UP IN THEIR EDGES STILL STATE
STAND AS WELL.
WE ALL BELIEVE THAT.
I DO* IS THE WILL TO GO.
THAT IS HOW WE CAN.
TEACH.
OTHER STUDENTS ON HOW TO ACCEPT
US FOR WHO WE OUR AND I JUST AS
WE OF THE LITTLE BRENT DOES NOT
MEAN THAT WE ARE.
RED RUBBER MORE.
FEATURES FIRST.
OF ALL THANK YOU HAVE NUMBER
HAVE DO BE WITH DIANE.
BAJA YOU KNOW WE'RE COOL BATTLE
AND WE IN.
A FIGHT GATHER SOME THAT WERE
MENTIONED HERE TODAY.
AND ALSO THAT GOD JAY STRIPPER.
J. BRODSKY IN JAIL.
ROSEN THE DA'S OFFICE IT IS
CRUCIAL THAT OUR SCHOOLS UP TWO
TRUCKS AND RECOGNIZE RACISM.
BULLION THAT DID NOT ALL FACETS
OF AMERICA AND THE WORLD AND THE
TECHNICAL BIASES AGAINST THEM
THE AMERICAN REVEREND RAISED IT.
THERE'S A PLACE BASIS OUR SCHOOL.
REPLACE OR COMMITTEES.
WHEN I OPENED TODAY AT THE CAME?
AHEAD AND AND ALL AS I HATED IT
INTO THIS BUILDING THE LAWS AND
THE LEADERS.
OF THE PACK BUYS WILL CALL PETER
BURNETT.
AS WITH BOOK ABOUT CHANGE THE
FACES OF RACISM AND ANTI
IMPERIALISM AND MARICOPA NEED TO
LOOK AT THAT SCHOOL SEARCHED THE
NAMES BURNETT.
MAYBE THE SOME MORE BEFORE FOR
FOR A LONG MINUTE REPRESENT
PEOPLE OF COLOR IN AND SOUGHT
AFTER SOME OF MY A A LATINO
ABOUT.
PERHAPS YOU LOOK AT CHANGE TO A
NAME THE BE FAVORABLE TO THAT IT
WILL TEAR DOWN RACE HATRED.
WHERE STAND IN HIS COUNTY?
ALSO EXIST.
THIRD FOURTH.
TWO THEN.
USE THIS.
CAN STILL BE ALLOWED IN THIS
CITY ACCOUNT.
AND I PUT.
THE EIGHT CONTAINING THE NEWS
SYMBOLS OF NOOSES SHOULD BE.
EIGHT USE NOR TIME BUT I THOUGHT.
THEN THIS.
OR BEING USED AS ANY FOR SO WE
HAD THAT ON AND ALLOW SYMBOL
BEYOND COUNTY.
WE MUST GIVE DAYS OFF PROCESSES
ALL STRAIGHTENED ON ON WHAT TYPE
OF PUNISHMENT BUT NOT ON AT
SCHOOL.
THIS IS A MUST FOR PRO.
TAPE.
HERE COUNTY HAVE HAD NO
WORKPLACE.
LIST CORPORATION THE BILL ONE
CAUSES THESE NEW THE POPPED UP.
AND ALSO HOW WE WRITE TO A
DISTANT TIME IS THE ONLY ONE
INCIDENT IT IS NOT ENOUGH AFTER
A LOT AGAINST.
BUT NOT INCLUDE WE MUST TAKE A
FIRM STAND AGAINST HATE THE SOME
OF THE FIND IT.
IS COUNTY IMMEDIATELY AND BASED.
FROM. TWO THOUSAND NINE THOUSAND
A GAME WITH HIS OFFICE AND SAYS
THAT I'M OF BY TWO LOOP IS WHAT
IS STATE.
AND DEALING WITH HATE CRIMES.
AGAINST PEOPLE OF COLOR.
AS WE WERE LAST POST AT LAST --
FIGHTING THAT INCIDENT.
WE HAVE TO DEAL WITH IT HERE IN
THE EAST SIDE.
INSTANCE EIGHT THAT POP UP.
WE MUST TAKE IT SERIOUSLY AND
WHEN JOB --
IT'S BETTER DID NOT PERFORMING
THE JOB.
DESPITE SOME.
MAKE THE STATEMENT THAT THE
WELLS TO THE BILL BUILT.
THE SERVICE PEOPLE OUT UP WE
NEED TO FACE IT AND THAT MAKES
THE WAY.
BUT TO GO. TO WEBSITES AND WHEN
THEY HAVE LEFT THE FOR PEOPLE TO
GET CONTACT THAT THAT --
FIVE YOU OF HATE CRIMES OR OR
MAYBE THE BULLET THE LINK TO SEE.
YOU HAVE TO GO ON AND SEARCH AND
LOOK AROUND AND AND TRY TO FIND
THE LINK THE CALL.
CAN'T PUT A COMPLAINT EVEN
WITHOUT OUR COUNTY WEBSITE YOU
HAVE TO LOOK.
UP TO FIND A RIPPLE.
EIGHT ONCE HAD NUMBERS HATE TO
OPEN SOMETHING UP ON YOU WITH.
YOUR MOST.
YOU HAVE ALL BEEN ABLE TO SEE
MAYBE FIND YOU NEED NEED TO HAVE
A READ.
BAILED.
THESE WORDS WEB AS WELL.
PERSONS REPORT HATE IMMEDIATELY.
WHICH IT.
AWAY.
BASED MAY TO ACCESS HATE CRIMES
BULLY.
WE'RE QUITE AS GOOD LIST. TO THE
SURVEYS AND ANNUAL OR BI ANNUAL
SESSION ACROSS TOWN.
I WAS BORN IN THE LIVING AREA
AMELIE SWIFTLY WITHOUT A TASTE.
THE GOAL BUT NOT PRESENT OR THE
POINT WAS TO TEACH AND A LOT.
THESE.
INCLUDING AND TRADERS.
SUPPORT.
SECURITY IS THAT.
OF THE VERY BEST MANIFESTATIONS
OF THE COMPANY TO ADDRESS HATE
TO THE INCLUDE PRESENT.
CONFLICT RESOLUTION METHODS.
IS WHAT FILE POINT AND THERE'S A
RACIAL RELIGION AND SEX STORE
ASMAN DISCRIMINATION AND HATE
CRIMES.
EVERY WEAPON IN SUCH AS THIS IS
FROM.
THE JOB EVERYONE IS COUNT.
WE WANT THIS COUNTY [INAUDIBLE]
TO HELP.
A DOCTOR KING'S.
DARKNESS GOT DARK ABOUT PARTNERS
ALL THE LIKE CAN DO THAT.
HOWEVER WE ARE HIS COUNTY WITH
HONEST WE AS COUNTY.
WAS THERE HAND.
DO OUR BEST TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT LET.
THAT'S ADMIN LATER WOULD NOT.
COUNTY IN ANY FORM FAST THANK
YOU.
READ MORE FUN TO MAKE THE STATE.
NOT JUST SHOULD HAVE SAID LUNA
TO THE COPYRIGHT IS LEFT TO THE
STATES THE RIGHT THANK YOU.
AND NEXT WE'LL HAVE THE JIMMY HE
CAN YOU ARE RICH COUNSELOR.
ON THE BILL WILL OPEN CENTER.
AND SOME.
ANTI WILL BE IN ACTION AND SOME
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS SOLD AT THE
CLOSE TO GO.
I HOPE THAT THEY GIVE ME.
CHRIS TAYLOR.
IDENTIFIES THE MAIL I AM HONORED
TO BE HERE TODAY BE THE TOPIC OF
HATE CRIMES VERY.
NEAR AND TO MY HEART BEAT YOU TO
SURVIVE A CRIME THAT HAD.
THERE IS A CODE THREE TERMS ON
THE OPERATING TABLE AND NOT ONLY
DO I PTSD BUT THE PARENTS ARE
UPSET.
BECAUSE THE TO THE TOP OF THE
CAPE CRAFTER VERY PROGRESSIVE
AND FAMILIES AS WELL AND CAN AT
A LOT OF MENTAL HEALTH.
RESEARCH AND FACT IS AS WELL --
I'M HERE TO TALK ABOUT THE BILL
WAS SENT OUT TO OUR ACCOUNT FOR
THEM.
AND I'M GONNA TALK ABOUT SOME
TRACK THAT WE'VE WITH ARE YOU
ARE GOING PROMISING CAN DROP ON
THE FOR RATHER IT.
SO AND IT TO DO A LOT OF WORK OR
SCHOOL ACCOUNT.
ARE OF THE SERVER WILL IT IS A
BIG THING THAT ARE YOU TALK
ABOUT SPECIFICALLY.
THE IDEA OF BEING CATFISH OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE COMMUNITY SELL --
BEEF AND AND THEN YOU KNOW THE
THING ABOUT CYBER BULLYING ISN'T
ALLOWED. TO REMAIN A NON THIS
AND THAT INTO DEFIES THE
FEELINGS AND DISCOMFORT FOR THAT
ITEM -- ALSO
WITH THE COMMUNITY THE O.
COMMUNITY WITH A SONG IS THAT
THE IS IT ASKED TALKS I SKIP.
THE NO FAT OFFEND AGE IS THAT
FOR AROUND ABOUT SEX AND ABOUT
PEOPLE PUT ON THE PROOF OF THE
DATE PROFILE BUT ARE YOU THERE
EXPERT -- TO
THE THERE IS THAT YEAH THAT ONE
GROUP STRUGGLE IS --
YOU KNOW OUT IS THE WINE AND YOU
KNOW I THINK WE JUST REALLY NEED
TO START TEACHING THAT LIKE WE
NEED TO COME TO THE DOOR ON THE
STATE --
ALSO FOR HOMELESS YOUTH BULLYING
BETWEEN THEMSELVES ARE NOT
RESPECTING PRONOUNS NOT SINGS A
NAME THAT THEY WANTED ME GOT MY
IDENTIFIED AS NOT RESPECT GENDER
IDENTITY EXHORTING CHAIR --
HOUSTON TIE LGBTQ LANGUAGE OR
HATE EACH BY SOME MEMBERS OF
PROFITS.
BY TEACHER AT THE THEM SUCH AS
AND ALSO A SUIT THAT YOU WILL BE
GETTING PER RENTAL TREAT AND FOR
SINCE WE YOU DROP AND SET GOALS
ADAM SIDE THE GENERAL POPULATION.
AND CENTER --
AND THEN YOU'LL HEAR USE FOR
THEIR SPECIAL TREATMENT BECAUSE
THEY HAVE THEIR OWN DROP IN OR
NOT STATING THAT SO TIMES ALL HE
NEEDS HAVE SKATE.
FOR THE GENERAL POPULATION --
AND WELL BEING --
SOME OF THE EFFORTS WE DO A BILL
IN CENTER --
WE DID A TRAIN THE TRAINER OF
BIRD FOR EAST SIDE UNION SCHOOL
JUST RETURN ALL OF THE SOCIAL
WORKERS FOR THE ENTIRE SCHOOL
DISTRICT.
I AND TING FOR WHERE.
FOR AFFIRMATIVE CHAIR FOR TRANS.
AND THEN THEY TOOK THAT BACK IN
EMPLOYMENT AND OTHER SCHOOL
SITES.
WE STRESS THE I KNOW PEOPLE TO
OF SIGNAGE EARLIER ON THE PATH
ALL.
MAKING THE ON DAN THAT NOT
HAVING ACCESS TO OUR STREET IS A
FORMER BULL.
IN THE STATE AND SEE.
I THINK IT'S JUST WITH EDUCATORS
IT WILL BE SUMMIT EDUCATORS ONLY
ROLE MODELS YOUTH HAVE SPECIALLY
HOUSE RULES --
AND SO I THINK THAT WE NEED TO
BE HAVING.
EXTENSIVE TRAINING FOR THE FORTY
EIGHT CWI.
ENTRANCE. FOR EDUCATIONAL
PROFESSIONALS AND AS WELL AS THE
STUDENTS THEMSELVES I FEEL IT
SHOULD BE TRAINING TOGETHER.
WE DO DURING THAT ONE OF THE
SURVEYS THAT WE USED --
FOR IN THE CHANGE FREEZE.
WE USE SOME RESEARCH FROM
GLISTEN WHICH IS THE GAY LESBIAN
AND STRAIGHT EDUCATION NETWORK.
AND THE NATION'S LEADING
NATIONAL EDUCATION ORGANIZATION
WORKING TO ITS EIGHT BILLS FOR
ALL.
AND THE FACT THAT THEY FOUND IS
CAN THE LGBTQ STUDENTS WITH NEWS
OF SCHOOL STAFF.
STUDENTS MANY IDENTIFIED AS
ELEVEN ARE MORE SUPPORTIVE STAFF
AT THEIR SCHOOL FOR SLATE D. TO
FEEL I'M IF.
LESS LIKE IN A MINUTE COOL THEY
HIRE GPA IS WERE LESS LIKELY TO
SAY THEY MIGHT NOT GRADUATE
SCHOOL AND FELT MORE CONNECTED
TO THEIR SCHOOL NITTY --
LGBT STUDENT THE GXS GENDER AND
SEXUALITY L. ANSWER SOME PEOPLE
CALL GAUGE THE LINE.
AT THERE STORES WILL LIKELY TO
FEEL UNSAFE AT THE SCHOOL OF
FROM NECK TO THE SCHOOL AND
THEIR COMMUNITIES AS WELL AND
SEVEN FIVE POINT 2% WOULD YOU BE
TO Q. STUDENTS IN SCHOOL.
WITH CLUES CURRICULUM SAID THERE
IS WERE ACCEPTING OF LGBTQ
PEOPLE COMPARED TO THIRTY NINE
POINT SIX FOR THE ROLE MODEL.
EDUCATE THE ROOM --
WERE STRUCK AN ARCH TO EDUCATE
NEEDED.
ON BULLYING HEADER SWEEP I DID
THAT.
IT HAS ALSO --
THE BATTLE ANTI LGBT Q. LANGUAGE
LIKE NO HOME UP AND OTHER.
THINGS YOUR NORMAL THAT THERE
ARE THE PEOPLE TO UNDERSTAND IT
IS VERY ANTI UP WE TO KILL AND
IS ALSO TO BE --
BECAUSE I FEEL LIKE YOU KNOW
THESE YOU ARE PICKING UP SO BEAR
AND THEY'RE GOOD BACK IN THERE
GROWING ANOTHER BECOMING
COMMUNITY MEMBERS AND THOSE NEW
MEMBERS TO BE.
PEOPLE LEAVE ATTACKING PEOPLE
AND YOU KNOW.
HURTING OTHERS WILL GIVE US THE
REST OF THE DO YOU THINK IT.
I'M AT THE AND THE HOUSE BUT THE
SUBTITLES CENTER.
LOS CHRIS WHETHER A TO BE HUGE
CENTER.
AND I I'M GOING TO KIND OF PIGGY
BACK UP OFF OF HIM A EDUCATION
SPECIFICALLY I'M UP PERSONAL.
AND I'M SO.
CRIME MOBILE HATE CRIMES THAT
WERE NEVER REPORTED.
I AND I THINK A LOT OF NEWS
CURRENT NOT YET.
COMPLETELY MAKE SENSE WHY WE
NEVER REPORTED IT I THINK THIS
IS TRUE FOR MOST MY PARTY.
AND THE WOMEN SING CURRENTLY
DESPITE.
NEVER.
GETS BECAUSE OUT --
MINORITY CAN INDEED.
WE ARE STANDARD PRESIDENT
VISIBLE BE AND NOW WE HAVE TO
COME TOGETHER AND SPEAK AS A
MOTHER AND HER MOTHER OF TWINS
WHO JUST RECENTLY STARTED
KINDERGARTEN.
AND THE FIRST WEEK OF* IN MY
GYM THING ALMOND ME THAT ONLY
FOR AMERICA TELLS GIRLS ARE ABLE
IS.
I HAD TO PULL.
OVER AND HAVE A CONVERSATION MY
KIDS HAVE QUEER THEIRS THEY ALSO
HAVE.
ANSWER WHERE WHICH BUILDER AND
SO IT'S NOT LIKE THEY WILL WHEN
A HETERO NORM BUBBLE.
ACTUALLY HAVE A BOOK OR FOR AN
AYE.
KING SHINS BAXLEY BENNETT SCHOOL
BECAUSE OF THAT NOS PARENT
ACTUALLY WANTS TO BE A PART OF
THE CLASSROOM EVERY BOOK TERO
NORMAN IF.
IT'S YOURS SET.
UP -- IT
THERE'S NOT REALLY A BASIS FOR
MY KIDS AS THEIR CITY IN
LEARNING INCREASE KILL THEM --
AND THAT'S BEEN REFLECTED ON THE
SCHOOLYARD WITH WHAT THE
CHILDREN ARE HEARING AT HOME
LINKUP OWN.
AND IT FAITH LEADER I'M OFF AND
SLEPT WITH WEAPONS AND AYE AYE
FATHER SON CHIEF.
AND CHILL AND ARE INVOLVED IN
FAITH COMMITTEES AND MY DAUGHTER
CAME THIS WEEK TELL ME THAT I
WAS GOING TO PROBABLY GO TO HELP
AND I DON'T THAT THE ANGELS LIKE.
INFORM ME BECAUSE YOU.
OTHER MOMMY --
I'M I'M TELLING DIES BECAUSE
CHILDREN ARE.
FIVE I NOW HAVE TO DEAL.
EMIKO CHAIR WITHIN MY HOME I AM
TRYING TO ON PACKET FIVE YEAR
OLD IS IN THE ANYBODY KIDS I
MEAN.
DOUBLE ANYWAY SO WE'RE WE'RE
DEALING WITH LATE.
WAS TO BE THE ONLY WAY TO REALLY
I DON'T KNOW HOW TO HAVE A JOB
IN MY FIELD I DON'T WANT TO BE
ABLE TO BE AT Q. ALMOST YOU.
AND THE ONLY WAY TO REALLY AND A
HALF AND THAT IT IS IN
PREVENTION AND EARLY PER CHEN
AND TO TELL YOU RIGHT NOW.
THAT PARENTS ARE GOING TO THE
RIGHT AND IT'S GOING TO BE GREAT.
THEY'RE GOING TO WRITE A THEY
ARE GONNA BE BACK AT IT YOU KNOW
HAVING YOU KNOW BOOKS AND SCHOOL
THAT FLAG TO YOU KNOW DIFFERENT
RELIGIONS AND COLORED AND THERE
IS A SAME SEX PARENTS.
MADE HIM PARENTS AS PARENTS MAY
BE IF IT ACTUALLY GOT A FIRE
THAT DIDN'T PAY THEIR MOM YEAH
THAT WOULD BE GREAT TO I'M JUST
TELLING THIS LIKE FOR PERSONAL.
DAYS DOES THIS WHAT I'M DEALING
WITH AT EVERY SINGLE DAY ON THE
NET WHEN THEY GET HOME --
A REAL IN ORDER TO GET AHEAD OF
MOST CRANES BEFORE THEY GET TO
THE POINT.
OUR YOUTH ARE LESS AND HAVE
SOUGHT OUT OUR SEX WITH.
THESE WAYS BUT AND WE NEED TO
LOOK AT HOW WE REALLY BRING THAT
AND SINCE THEY'RE TWO UP SUPPORT
THAT YOU HAVE TO BE A PERSON
THAT WAS IN OUR COUNTY.
YEAH.
THANK YOU.
ANNEX WE HELP PAULA.
HELLO.
ALL RIGHT.
I'M GLAD.
TO THE MEMBER AS AND WHEN
EVERYONE WHO IS HERE TODAY YOU
SO MUCH INVITE ME.
THE PATH THAT I AM NOT.
A BIG ORDER NATION I I'M MORE OF
A CHANCE TABLING ACTIVIST.
BECAUSE OF THE YOU YOU READ IT
FOR YEARS OF BUT BASICALLY I AM
ANTI.
SINCE THE YEAR TWO AND A LOT.
AND DURING THE TIME I SPOKE AT
OUR CHURCH IS OF SCRUPLES IN
HIGH SCHOOL CLUBS.
AS HOW.
SO MANY DIFFERENT PLACES IS THE
SUMMER SPOKE MY FIRST CONFERENCE
WHICH WAS VERY.
EXCITED BUT I'M.
I I AM HERE THEY SAID BEFORE NOT
TO REPRESENT MAYES AGENT BUT TO
REPRESENT A BIG INDIVIDUAL WHO'S
HAD VERY FEW.
ADVOCATES FOR LIFE [INAUDIBLE]
THIS.
THAT DID NOT HAVE MANY SINCE.
AND E. AS THIS.
CALL VOTES.
TELL YET [INAUDIBLE]
FOR SHE AS DON.
AND FROM THEN ON TO THE PRIVACY
GRADUATE.
SHE HAD BEEN.
THE GET OF PHYSICAL BULLYING HAD
BEEN IT ISN'T EVEN AS EARLY AS
SIX SHE HAD A A VISION MOST IN
ABOUT AN HERBAL STATE SAID TO
HER.
RIGHT IN HER FACE.
INCLUDING THINGS NEVER SHE HAD
EVER.
SHIN THE NEVER X..
FORCE RACES.
AND TM.
SHE EXPERIENCED.
SEXUAL. THREE YEAH.
FROM SEVENTH GRADE HI.
STOOD UP.
AT AND JUST TO JUST PACKING HER.
SCHOOL.
SOMEONE IMPERSONATE HER FACEBOOK.
AND SHE DIDN'T KNOW ABOUT IT
BECAUSE SHE RIFFAGE REFUSE TO GO
TO FACEBOOK.
SO THAT.
PEOPLE WOULDN'T BE.
ON HER PASSAGE HER WITH HATE
JEWS.
CALLS AT BY THAT TIME SHE HAD
GONE TO CALL.
SHE THE I KNOW WHAT.
YOU KNOW WHO THEY ARE BUT THEY
WOULD SET THINGS PHONE --
THIS CALL.
I'D.
BEEN STOPPED HAD.
HAD TO PUT SO MUCH.
AND SO.
I'M COMING TO YOU TODAY AS
SURVIVOR.
AS SOMEONE WHO [INAUDIBLE]
I ROGER [INAUDIBLE]
EIGHT OKAY.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT IS
HAPPENING.
AND IT IS HAPPENING NOW AND
STYLE I COME.
AS SPEAKER RATHER THAN THE THAN
THE FEW YEARS BUT DO YOU WITH
SOME.
DS FOR HOW CAN.
IS STONE --
AS A SURVIVOR BUT ALSO AS A
RESEARCHER AT PARTIES VERSUS
STARTING COLLEGE IN SUCH A LACK.
OF WEEK.
HIS EX LIED.
YOU'LL ACTUALLY SEE THAT.
I'M.
I AM.
NOT [INAUDIBLE]
THE ONE ONE AT EVERY. THREE
CHILDREN EXPEDIENCE BY.
AMERICA NEAR JUST NORTH OKAY.
BLOWN.
THIS IS A PRETTY HIGH PERCENTAGE
OF AND SO IN ORDER OKAY THAT'S
HOW COMBAT THIS TO AND IN A DEAL
WITH.
HERE TO TALK ABOUT.
READ THESE AGGRESSOR DON'T LIKE.
WHAT IS A GREAT COME?
AND BE ABLE. TO ALSO WANT TO
TALK ABOUT WHO ARE THE MOST
VULNERABLE BULLYING.
AND THIS IS ACTUALLY SOMETHING
IN MY POST FACEBOOK OF A I WOULD
LIKE TO SHOW EDUCATION BECAUSE I
THOUGHT IT WAS SO TRUE.
VINCE. TO SCHOOL TO EARN
[INAUDIBLE]
IT IS COULD ALSO PUSH THAT TO
BECOME AN AGGRESSOR.
WE SEE THAT.
IT ENDS ON THE YEAR A GOOD YOUR
IN SO WE SEE AN INCREASE OF
BULLYING AND PEAKING SINCE FIFTH
SIXTH AND SEVENTH GRADE.
AND THEN IT NO LEVELS A HI
BALLOONS INTO SEEING CHAIR.
WE IF WE WANT TO DO.
IF WE WERE TO CALL OUT AND STOP.
THAT PEAK WINNING IT DOT
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL IT IS READ.
UP.
HE WAS BUT WITH TEACHING THEM I
DIFFERENT.
PERMISSION STRATEGIES AND HOW TO
DEAL WITH HER AND THE QUESTION
WE HAVE STUDENTS --
WITH AN AT CAESARS SCHOOLS FIND
STUDENTS WHO HAVE.
TAKER THE RIGHT ASK.
SINCE OUR RIGHTS OF OUR
COMMISSION MEETING EACH OTHER
FEMALES --
EXPERIENCE MOST.
OF WHICH I AM.
EDIT DISABILITY A METAL --
WHETHER IT'S PHYSICAL WHETHER
IT'S DEPRESSION OR ANXIETY --
BASICALLY ANYTHING THAT.
GETS YOU FROM THE NEW ARM.
WHAT WILL MAKE YOU? TO PUSH
SOMEONE --
TO AS WELL WHAT CAN MAKE THEM.
TO BE ABLE.
TO AND FOR I FOR SIR.
THEY ARE VERY LIKELY --
TO IF THAT OF EXPERIENCE --
BULLY IN THE IN THE HOME BETWEEN
THEIR PARENTS OR THEIR BELOW
THEM.
OR IF THEY'RE LEFT ALONE IN A
COLLECTED THEM.
SO WE GO TO THE NEXT SLIDE --
WE SEE THAT WE HAVE SO MANY
THINGS WE NEED.
TO DRESS WE WANT DRESS.
HE ALSO ADDRESSED RACISM SEXISM
ABLE AS A HOME FOR ALL THE AT
ISMS.
SURVIVORS YEAH.
TAKES THE ROLE WING CARPET NEED
TO WORK ON A MEETING I TEACH AND
EDUCATING OUR SURE TO SEE A
BURKE SAID YOUR CHIN.
AND HOW --
TO APPROPRIATELY DEAL AT WE NEED
TO REDUCE THEM TO FRIENDS.
I'M.
DIFFERENT STYLES ARE DIFFERENT
CULTURES SO IT'S NOT FOR IT TO
THAT [INAUDIBLE]
ON THERE'S SO MUCH YOU CAN.
RIGHT TO LIFE IS THAT ON THIS IS
[INAUDIBLE]
PLEASE.
HELLO THE YOU GUYS RAVENOUS MY
NAME IS VIA HIS ARM ESTIMATES
AND TM YET HERE AT RIVER LET ME
IN OUR SCHOOL AND ASK STUDENTS
WHO ARE ACTUALLY EXPERIENCES.
FIRSTHAND --
WE KINDA WANT TO ADDRESS THE THE
KIND OF THE INSIDE IS AMONG THE
SCHOOL MONDAY FEATURES IN THIS
INSTANCE.
AND HAVE --
WE ARE NOT INFORMED THAT WE NEED
TO BE MORE AWARE OF LIKE
EVERYTHING WE'RE GOING THROUGH
IN PEOPLE THEY'RE GOING THROUGH
AT NO YOU HAVE BROUGHT SOME
SOLUTION THAT.
WE CAN PROVIDE YOU.
OKAY SO WHAT THIS WILL DO IS WE
ABOUT WAS AXE.
WHITE --
PROPOSING MAYBE LIKE I'VE
STUDIED CAUGHT IS A LOT OF WHAT
WE SEE ARE CORRECT FORM IN.
HOST TRACK AND THEN ABOUT AND
DOING AND OR A NEW KIND OF
PUSHING THAT.
I WANTED IT DONE ABOUT AGENDA --
DO A VERY MAJOR DISSERVICE TO
OUR NUCLEAR DIVERSE POPULATION
OF WANT TO BE ABLE TO RELATE TO
SOMETHING I WANT TO BE ABLE --
TO YEAH I JUST BE EASIER TO
FOCUS AND I WERE REALLY
SOMETHING AND UP [INAUDIBLE]
GOD.
ANOTHER WAY THAT LIKE WE THOUGHT
WE COULD DO THIS IS THAT.
SINCE I IN ANOTHER CLASSMATE WE
ACTUALLY ARE SOPHOMORE YEAR WELL
THAT WAS IT.
GROUP THAT TEENAGE OF A TEEN
IMMUNITY IS SO HE ADDED FORM.
AND WITH THIS WE WANT TO CREATE
LIKE UNITY WHERE HE WHERE A
LITTLE LIKE.
US STUDENTS KID COME IT WILL
COME BULLET AND KNOW THEIR PLACE
FOR THEM BECAUSE OUR SCHOOL IS
ABOUT 40%.
STUDENTS OR WE THAT AND NO UNION.
ONE OF MY YEARS FROM.
ABOUT IT ME.
AND I THINK IT WAS DECIDED IF
YOU ABOUT IT BECAUSE OVER THE
YEARS.
THE THING THEY DO MANY OTHER
THAN THE ENGINE.
WELL OUR COUNTRY AND TO OTHER
COUNTRIES.
WITH THE KIND OF WHEN YOUR BOOKS
THEY MORE COOL BY THE U. S. YOU
DON'T REALLY HERE THE TIRES
STORY.
SO WHEN I GOT TO MY FRESHMAN
YEAR LIKE ALL THESE STORIES
UNLIKE.
SITE OTHER STREET KNOW ABOUT.
THE PRICE I KNOW ALL THESE FACTS
I'D EVEN HEARD OF BEFORE BECAUSE
OF THE FACT THAT ARE HERE THREE
BOOKS AND ROTISSERIE WHICH
RECALL WHICH THE SEEDS THAT HAVE
THE ROLE JUST TO DO WITH THE U.
S..
BASE THE ONLY TALK ABOUT THE U.
S. ASIDE AND WHAT THE U. S. FOR
THEM.
BECAUSE I THINK IT'S A GOOD IDEA
OF ETHNICS IS SO MORE PEOPLE CAN
LEARN MORE ABOUT THEIR CULTURE
AND THOSE WHO DON'T KNOW ABOUT
THEIR CULTURE BECAUSE EITHER.
THEIR PARENTS --
HAVE BEEN EXPLAINED TO THEM IT
THINK OR FOR OTHER REASONS THEY
OKAY --
THINK THAT I'D LIKE TO ADDRESS
IS NOT ONLY LIKE THE STUDENTS
THE MORNING BE MORE ACTIVE WHERE
OF WHAT'S GOING ON ON WITH THAT
BALEEN BUT ALSO THE TEACHER IS --
PUT INTO BEEN IMPRIMER EFFORT
WE'VE HAD.
UP MAKE MINCE LAKE --
I DON'T NEXT IN AND STUFF LIKE
THAT AND I THINK THIS STARTING
WITH.
IT MAKES THE STUDENTS THINK IT'S
OKAY -- I
HAVE FOR THEM TO STAY REMARKS
LIKE JUST AS THEY HAVE --
BASICALLY PEOPLE THEY'RE LOOKING
UP TO AND THE ONE THAT.
SAVES THING SO IT'S A THING TO
JUST CHANGE THE STUDENTS BUT
ALSO THE TEACHERS.
THAT NOT ONLY THAT IT LIKE IT'S
IT'S RIGHT THE T. TO KNOW HOW TO
ACT THIS WAY BUT SO THIS IS FOR
ME COMFORTABLE AND LIKE.
RIP.
AND THE THAT LATE IF THE REPORT
IT LIKE.
SOMETHING GOING TO BE DONE AND
THAT IT'S NOT AS WE SEE IN THEIR
VOICE NOT ACTUALLY KNOW WHAT.
ALSO -- I
FEEL THAT TEACHERS NEED MORE
TRAINING ON HOW TO BE ABLE TO DO.
IT WAYS THE FIRST ONES AND FROM
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE I CAN SAY
THAT UP IN THE SEAT I AND THAT
REALLY.
WORKS -- WAY
IN WHICH I WILL LEARN BECAUSE I
DON'T HAVE THAT SUPPORT SO I'M
NOT [INAUDIBLE]
I THOUGHT.
ORANGE ASK GIN AND DOES.
AND A MEANS I THINK THAT'S JUST
AND OKAY I'M ON ANOTHER SMALL
CHANGE OF TOPIC I ALSO WANTED A
DOES THE FACT OF GIN BASED RULES
IN SCHOOL WAY BE.
LOOK AT WHAT.
ROSE IS BUOYED.
WHATEVER NOTE OF THESE GROWING
UP WAS NUMBERED THING UP AND
TEACHERS IT UP IS WITH THE
DISTRICT WANTS TO THE EXTENT
THEY NEED.
THEY MUST BE REACHED DRESS AND
ALL THAT WHICH RELATES TO WHAT
RECORDS ARE GOING TO SEE WAS
SAYING EARLIER.
ABOUT SEX FLOOR AND BEGINS.
HAVING PEOPLE TELL US WHAT TO
WEAR NOT.
BE TELL.
OTHERS --
THIS IS SUPPOSED TO BE LIKE
WOMEN OTHER PEOPLE BECAUSE I'M
AN OBVIOUS YOU AREN'T THE SURE.
SHIN CHAN AND BROUGHT HIS CLASS
AN ENTIRE.
LATINO X. ASSOCIATION FOR SO
PLEASE STAND UP.
OPEN THE PANEL --
THAT X. ASSOCIATION MEMBERS AND
THANK [INAUDIBLE]
BERMAN WHETHER [INAUDIBLE]
READ [INAUDIBLE]
THE A GROUP HERE AND WHAT'S THE
OF LESS GOVERNMENT GOOD OR
WONDERFUL PAUL.
WHO SPECIALLY THANK THOSE PEOPLE
WHO HAVE THE COURAGE? TO THROUGH.
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE WITH WITH
LIST SO THANK YOU VERY VERY MUCH.
I HEARD A COMMON THREAT HERE
YOU'LL OF THE SUCH A DIVERSE --
A PILOT IS THAT WE SHOULD
SHORTLY OR OWNED A PROBLEM.
NO WE SHOULD RUSSIA REALIZED
THAT ATTACK ON ONE OF US.
IS ATTACK.
OF TWO ON ONE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH [INAUDIBLE]
FOR REYES.
AND MANY OF YOU. TWO ONE TWO SIX
HUNDRED A STUDENT.
FINALLY I HAD IT WOULD.
HAVE A BILL TO AT REQUIRE THE
SCHOOL TO NOTIFY YOUR STUDENTS
AND THEIR PARENTS AT LEAST TWICE
A YEAR ALL THE MEDICAL.
SERVICES IN THE COMMUNITY.
NEXT YOUR LOCAL WORK WITH JOSH
TWO POINT TO TO TO IDENTIFY
SOMETHING IMPENDING.
FOR WOULD BE ABLE TO HELP MENTAL
HEALTH OF AND COUNSELING
SERVICES IN EVERY SCHOOL AND
THAT WILL ALSO HELP WITH MANY OF
THE USED THOSE [INAUDIBLE]
ADDRESSING.
EIGHT IF YOU HAVE ANY.
QUESTIONS OR HOW THEY YEAH YES
THANK YOU SO MUCH SIR MEMBERS TO
AND AND YOU KNOW I'M NOT SOME
YOU FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS TO BE
A MEETING FOR THE FIRST TIME BUT
THAT WAS FOR THE AND ALWAYS.
VERY INSTRUCTIVE FOR ME.
UP AND I HAVE VERY POWERFUL AS
WE PULL UP AND I SEARCH FOR LOVE
HAVE -- MOM
THE PRESENT IT IN AND WILL HAVE
MY A STOP [INAUDIBLE]
CERTAINLY.
NO BUT I WAS ASIAN PRESENT YOUR
IDEA MUMBLING BUMBLING MAPS SO
I'M VERY IMPRESSED WITH YOUR
ABILITY TO ARTICULATE SELLS A
VERY EFFECTIVE MANNER AND SO
CLOSE TO YOU.
AND I ARE TO MENTION WE DO A
BILL THAT --
MAYBE FULLY SUPPORTED.
TO CALL THE CUSTOMER.
AB.
TWO SEVEN SEVEN THE SEVEN
SEVENTY TWO SO THEY CAN DO THAT.
WHICH WOULD REQUIRE.
STUDIES AS CARMEN A GRADUATION
[INAUDIBLE]
I'M [INAUDIBLE]
THIS PROBLEM.
AND BEGINS TO THE GOVERNOR
VETOED IT.
AND YOU KNOW TO GET INTO --
IN HIS MESSAGE AND AND AND I
THINK HE'S A GREAT THINGS IT WAS
AND THIS IS I DON'T AGREE ON S.
[INAUDIBLE]
S..
WITH THIS QUIZ THEM ABOUT.
THE GRADUATION REQUIRED A
SPECIALIST IS ALREADY OVER BUT A
MULTI TASK AS HOURS OF HOMEWORK.
THAT I I DON'T AGREE WITH.
SO THERE ARE A LOT OF BIRDS ARE
STUDENT I THINK THAT.
IS WHAT'S MOST SIGNIFICANT
IMPORTANT AND I THINK THINK
STUDIES IS CRITICALLY IMPORTANT.
OF MY OWN FAST ACCESS.
BEING BRUTALIZED.
AND IT MAKES ME SAD THAT.
THAT.
IS ALSO GOING THROUGH IT AND THE
MORE.
PEOPLE IN AND THE DOOR OPEN JUST
A SHAME AS KEEP THE CALL SHORT
STORY -- SO
THAT WE CAN CONTINUE TO FIGURE
OUT WHAT WE NEED TO DO A BETTER
JOB.
OF A PERSON SCHOOL DISTRICT
STATE LEVEL LAWN MOWERS MEANT
YOU NAME IT --
WE NEED TO BE ACTING UP TO THIS
HAVEN'T DONE A GOOD ENOUGH JOB.
I THE OPPORTUNITY TO DO BETTER.
AND SO I'M VERY GRATEFUL FOR YOU
SHARING AND THE THE THE LAST
THING I MENTIONED BECAUSE
ABSOLUTELY COMMITTEE THE SCARE.
OF TO A TWO HOUR THAT WORK VERY
WELL TOGETHER AND I THINK WE'RE
LUCKY --
CERTAINLY BEING A SEPARATE CAN
THAT WE DO AND CHRISTIAN ASH.
YOU MENTIONED SOMETHING THINK
THAT AS WE TALK ABOUT THE WORK
WE'RE DOING ANTI BULLYING AS IT
APPLIES TO FACE.
AT THE RACE AND HAVE BEEN THESE
POWERFUL PLAYERS HERE.
WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE.
THAT WERE WERE WORKING IN A VERY
INTENTIONAL NAY.
IN COMBATING.
HOMOPHOBIA.
HATRED TOWARD.
YOU CAN SEE I THINK THAT THERE'S
NO DOUBT.
THAT.
YOU WILL IN.
THEM.
OFTEN TIMES NOT.
OFTENTIMES IT'S COME THROUGH --
THE MISINTERPRETATION
MISAPPLICATION OF FAITH THAT WE
HAVE.
THE THE HATE IT NOT THAT WE HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY. FOR THOSE OF
THE UNDERSTAND AND WORK WITH
FAITH LEADERS ACTUALLY GO.
AS AS BOTH WEEKS POSSIBLE I TO
COMBAT.
SOME OF THE DANGERS OF BATIK
COMMITTEE.
AND TO BE IS WELCOMING AND AND
AND WITH HIS OPEN ARMS AS
POSSIBLE ALSO. TO BE PROACTIVE
AND MAKE SURE THAT WITHIN OUR
OWN COMMUNITIES WHERE THERE'S A
SUBDIVISION COMMITTEE OR GETTING
THOUGH --
WITH THE OTHER STATES HERE THAT
WE ARE NOT ONLY SEEKING OUT
WHICH IS TO PROTECT --
COMBAT THE THE THE BULLYING
AGAINST --
THE SPECIFIC IT'S OF THE CITIES
USING OUR VOICE AS WELL MAKE
SURE WITHIN OUR OWN COMMUNITY
WITH THAT THAT WERE BUT NOT JUST
SPEAKING.
CHECKING WHEN THERE'S AND TO
LGBT Q. ACTIONS OR OR
PRIVATIZING IT.
YOU HAVE MORE PROACTIVE PROGRAMS --
IS A VERY DIFFICULT.
CONVERSATIONS HAVE ALL.
I CAN TELL IN ASIAN AMERICAN.
SOME OF IT.
AND I SAID WHAT I SAID ABOUT
THEIR OWN COMMUNITY BUT THERE'S
A THERE'S A LOT.
OF FUN AND HOMOPHOBIA --
THAT DOESN'T GET DISCUSSED.
IS WE DON'T TALK ABOUT A WEEK
AFTER ITS LEADERS WE HAVE TO
TALK ABOUT IT.
AS PART OF THE YOUR STORY IS --
CHRIS THAT WAS ALSO VERY
POWERFUL AND AND AND I KNOW THAT
ALL OF US BRING OUR OWN STORIES
THAT'S WHY WE'RE DOING THIS WORK.
ENDS OF USE FOR TAKING SO LONG
TO THANK YOU ALL SO MUCH AND
LOOK FORWARD. TO WORK WITH ALL
OF THE CONTRA AND WITH.
NO.
THE NEW GOVERNOR SO WE'LL
CONTROLLABILITY IN.
ALL RIGHT AND ALLOW ME TO THE
SAME.
NUMBER.
REYES BECAUSE IT PUT OUR HEADS
THIS SITE WANNA DO INTERPERSONAL
THANK YOU TO EAT EVERYONE BO.
AND THERE'S SOMETHING I WANT TO
DO IS JUST A RAISE TO
OPPORTUNITIES.
OF THE COUNTY WILL BE BRINGING
FORWARD IN --
TO OUR BOARD.
IN -- ON
NOVEMBER THE SIX EIGHT AND
INCREASE IN FUNDING THAT WE ARE
INVESTING IN INTIMATE PARTNER
VIOLENCE.
BUT IS UPSET ABOUT WILL HAVE --
A AND I I THINK I'LL TALK TO A
RELATIVE.
TO I'M NOT TRYING.
TO PREVENT ON IT THEM OVER
ANOTHER BUT REALLY HOW WE THINK
ABOUT THIS AND A MORE UNIVERSAL
WAY WILL BE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
OUR COUNTY STEP.
VERY BIG TO THE PREVENTION --
ENVIRONMENT AND SO THAT'S THE
FIRST THING I WANTED TO COMMENT
ON THE SECOND COMMENT IS IT
TUESDAY OUR BOARD WILL BE
PUTTING ON RESOURCES OR EIGHT
TRANS -- ON
TRANSMITTAL HOUSING UP AT THIRTY
THAT WILL --
HOUSE I THINK OLDER TEENS AND
YOUNG ADULTS.
AND THAT IS SO.
THE REASON REYES IS A PART OF
THE REASON THAT.
YOU CAME TO US WAS ONE OF
HEARING THAT THAT --
LIKE CHAIRED THE COMMUNIQUE
MOUNTAIN YOU KNOW TALK TO WHAT
THEY WERE LIVES OR MOVING IN
THAT DIRECTION SO.
I WANT TO SAY THANK YOU FOR THE
INFORMATION SO SAY OF LET'S GET
TO WORK.
THANK YOU.
BROUGH MODE FOR AS WE WE'RE IN
THE THIRD PANEL TO COME ON THAT
DAY -- SO
WE'LL TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY
[INAUDIBLE]
TO CHINESE.
UNCOMMON OF I THINK I MADE THE
COMMENT AND THANK MY STAFF --
ON MY LAP TO MY RIGHT HERE AND
ALSO INTRODUCE MY JUST
[INAUDIBLE]
HOW?
INCOME FROM THE RAFTERS.
AND ALSO.
FROM.
MY ARMONK.
IS WRONG HERE ALL ALONG WITH
[INAUDIBLE]
WAIT [INAUDIBLE]
AND NANCY.
AND AS MASS MASS.
AT THE MOMENT.
PRESENTATION.
WOULD THE SERVER [INAUDIBLE]
LISTEN.
THEY HAVE ALSO [INAUDIBLE]
YOUR SO.
IS THE BEST.
AND WE WILL START WITH THERE
THAT ARE --
THAT THE OF US IN OUR QUEUE
PLEASE AND ACROSS THE NATION
FEEL.
ESPECIALLY AND THESE RECENT
TIMES I THINK THAT IN ORDER FOR
US MAGE USES.
TALK ABOUT IT.
AND TO TO READ AND I GREATLY
HOLD BY OUT THOSE WHO SPOKE
BEFORE ME.
AND AT IS EVER PRESENT EVENT
EDUCATION AND EDUCATORS. FOR ALL
THOSE WHO HAVE.
DRAWINGS WOULD LIKE.
TO FLEE APOLOGY ASSEMBLY.
FOR DOES OF APPS.
ARE SUPPOSED TO BE FOR TING AND
PROVIDED WITH FROM BACK SOON TO
LEARN.
IT WOULD BE TASK AHEAD OF US AND
WE DO NEED TO CONTINUE THE DO I
CAN'T SO THAT OUR STUDENTS.
AND OUR EMPLOYEES.
THIS.
WEEK I HAD FORTUNE TO MEET WITH.
THE MUSLIM CALL.
SHIN EXCHANGE.
AND YOUNG MANY OF THEM --
RENT IDEAS SHARED WITH A PROGRAM
THAT I WENT TO INSTITUTE IN MICE
DISTRICT FILED WITH THE PEACE.
I EXPLAINED THAT THIS IS A VERY
A SIMPLE.
I'M.
SET BLACK COMMITTEE WHERE A
STUDENT LEADERS.
MEET US AT OUR STUDENTS WERE TOO
WEAK JEN SYMPATHY TO GET TO KNOW
ONE ANOTHER.
BECAUSE IT WAS A RIGHT.
HANDED AND STUDIES OF AND IT
THAT [INAUDIBLE]
WE TO GROUPS THAT.
HATE CRIME AS BECAUSE BECAUSE
THE TO HELP US.
BEING.
BEST.
AND AT THE CENTER OF BOB YOU --
WITH THE PEACE WITH.
IT IS PRICED [INAUDIBLE] TO
EXCUSE TO WITH OTHERS.
ARMS -- BEEN
WHO THEY ARE.
AND THEN.
I'M SURE THAT WITH A GREAT MOVIE
AND YOU HAVE CRESCENT A MUCH.
IF A COMPANY IS THAT FORTY
DEPLOYMENT ASSETS.
WELL DOWN TO NHL READ IT DOES IS
IT PROVIDES THE STUDENTS AS THE
LINK AGAIN ESSENCE PURPOSE.
AND HELPS TO TAKE OWNERSHIP OF
THE ENVIRONMENT IS TEACHES THEM.
TO NOTICE THAT --
CRAB GRASS IS A TEACHING THEM
STRATEGIES ON WHAT TO DO WHEN
THEY NOTICED THAT.
AND IT'S TARGETING --
STUDENTS WHO HAVE INFLUENCE OVER
A DOZEN BECOME THEM BACKERS.
AND SO FOR EXAMPLE ONE STUDENT
ID WITH ME YESTERDAY.
THAT. FOR NO ONE ON THEIR LIST.
THAT SOME IS BEING PUT DOWN --
WAY HE LOOKS OR THINKS OR ACT.
THEY THE DAY OF TOOLS TO EITHER
DISTRACT --
TO CHANGE THE SUBJECT. TO AS
THEY SAID.
DIRECT AND FIND AND A. CATER. TO
MAIL YOU CHANGE X. CLASS.
AND RESEARCH DEMONSTRATES THAT
SUSPENSIONS --
CREASED ABOUT 30% AFTER FIRST
YEAH IMPLEMENTATION.
AND A BIG REASON FOR THAT IS
THAT.
MAC DID THAT.
THAT THEY'RE VALUED AND FEEL
THAT DIGNITY IS INTACT AND HAVE
ABOUT OTHER STUDENTS --
DISTRICT.
SOME OF THE THINGS WE HAVE
ACROSS I DISTRICT --
POSITIVE BEHAVIOR IN TERMS
INTERVENTION STEP.
AND SO I THIS BILL IS.
AND AN AXE.
BACKED CAMPAIGN [INAUDIBLE]
AS TEN TO NINE AGAIN YES DIFF OF
VALUE. TO FEEL RESPECTED TO FEEL --
THAT THEY DINED AT ONE ANOTHER.
SOME OTHER ASPECTS AS SHOULD
ALSO THE PREVIOUS PANEL IS.
OF ETHNIC.
CENTRIC STUDY.
AND A RASH RIGHT.
LATINO.
M. A. R. LAX AND MY CAN ANCESTRY
IT ENDS.
STEP STREET OF THOSE AFTER WE
BEEN POWER.
AND THAT WE NEED TO BE MINDFUL
OF THAT AND IN THIS NEXT HISTORY
OPTION.
SURE THAT.
SOUNDS BUT THOSE BOOKS WHICH ARE.
BACK [INAUDIBLE]
APPLE.
AND SET FREE AMAZON.
AS SO THAT OUR STUDENTS CAN FEEL.
THAT THEY SEE THEMSELVES THEY
SEE THEMSELVES NOT IT PRESS
PEOPLE AS PEOPLE WHO RISE
[INAUDIBLE]
BIG.
THOSE WERE THE BROWN FAMILY --
INITIATIVES AT OUR STUDENTS CAN
SAYS STREET.
I CAN --
IT'S THE WAY IT AND IN ORDER FOR
S. -- TO
REALLY REALLY [INAUDIBLE]
EIGHT NATION --
WELL.
VALUE FOR THEY ARE.
WE DO START WITH OUR STUDENTS
AND THEY STEP ONCE AND I KNOW
THAT WE HAVE BEFORE AS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO REALLY MAKE GREAT
CHANGE.
AT THANK YOU AGAIN FOR HAVE HERE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU GOT TO HAVE YOU HERE
I'M I'M SPEAK TO WELL WHAT.
NOT ON BY THE THE OKAY
[INAUDIBLE]
WOMEN'S.
I'M REALLY IS BELTON'S DAN A CAR
AT THE ELEMENTARY LEVEL TODAY
THAT'S WHAT I OF THE MONTH
KNOWLEDGE OF IN OUR ON OUR
DISTRICT --
AS AS WELL AS ACT ANNEX AND PART
OF OUR PROCESS.
IN THE LAST TWO YEARS TO REALLY
START WORKING ON POSITIVE
BEHAVIOR SUPPORT.
EVENTS FOR P. B. S. I WANT
BIGELOW TO THAT.
PART OF WHAT I THINK I'M HEARING
IS A LOT OF TIMES WE GET THE
KIDS NEED TO BE TAUGHT THANKS AS
EARLY AS ELEMENTARY SCHOOL.
AND SO IN OUR SCHOOLS THAT ARE
ELEMENTARY SCHOOLS WERE LOOKING
AT WHAT IS IT LOOK LIKE TO BE IN
OUR SCHOOL WE CHOSE FLOOR WHERE
THE BOBCATS SO WE ARE.
SERVERS THAT MEANS TO BE
RESPECTFUL HAVING HOUSE THAT IT
OUGHT TO BE STIFF AND
RESPONSIBLE.
AND THROUGHOUT OF ART TO NUMBER
I'D LINES --
WE HAVE LESSON PLANS THAT ARE
THE TEACHERS ARE ALL YOU IS IN
TERMS OF THE LOOK TO BE
RESPECTFUL WITH PEOPLE WORK OKAY
SAFE IN THE CLASSROOM.
GROUND IN HAPPENED YET.
IN MIND HOW DO WE ACT HAPPY TREE
RATHER AND WE TRY TO USE COMMON
LANGUAGE THOUGH IF WE SEE
SOMEONE THAT IS NOT DOING THE
RIGHT THING IS.
IS THAT THAT.
ARE YOU IN STATE ARE YOU IN AN
ASSET AS OKAY NEEDY RESPONSIBLE.
AND I DO IT TO THE STUDENTS AND
ONE LANGUAGE WITH US AND THAT'S
REALLY NOT.
THAT AND ALSO OF THE PIECES THAT
WERE WERE YOU NOT FEEL IT SYSTEM
OF MANAGED TO DO.
SO HOW DO.
IN IT TO GET THAT WE LOOK AT IT
AT LEAST OKAY I COULD BE HOW YOU
DOING. FOR RECOGNIZE IN THAT
THAT'S THE ONLY THING THE MAP.
BUT NOW WE'RE UP SO TRACK BEHAVE
ADAM SO ARE WE HAVING PROBLEMS
IN THE CLASSROOM AND WHAT IS IT
SO WE HAD TOOL LOOKING AT MADE
AND MANNERS A COP WHAT KIND OF
THINGS ARE SEEN.
LEADERSHIP THEM ONLY ME TWICE
NOW ONE OF THE DUPLICATE ADAPT
BEHAVIOR.
IS THERE A BOOSTER THAT WE NEED
TO DO IS --
VERY THAT WE NEED TO BE
CONCERNED ABOUT AND IF KEEP POP
UP ON THAT GREATER HAVE A A
SECONDARY COMMITTEE FOR WELLNESS
TEAM.
AND YOU TAUGHT EMERGED UP THERE.
WE HAVE ONE THAT ARE RIGHT NOW
DAYS A WEEK AND THE MAY I HAVE A
LOT SINCE BIRTH ASSEMBLY
THERAPIST ON STAFF.
THAT WORKS WITH STUDENTS AND
FATE ISN'T SOME LIKE BILL WILSON
OR WHATEVER THEY NEED ON THE
OUTSIDE.
WE ALSO HAVE COUNSELING IN
CHARGE.
AND THAT REAL OF THAT OF ALSO.
DEPEND THE INTERNET WE HAVE THE
SO IT WOULD BE NICE OF FOR THE
ARTS THAT THERAPISTS AND ENTER
THE FACT.
BUT OVER IT IS A REAL BETTER
SKIPTON HELP WITH WITH IS AN ODD
BAR.
AND THROUGH THE WORK OF OUR
WELLNESS TEAMS SO WE CAN LOOK AT
OTHER OPTIONS LIKE WE HAVE A
CHECK IN CHECK OUT OFTEN SO WE
HAVE A PERSON IN THE MORNING
THAT MEETS FILED IT SCHOOL AND
SET.
YOUR HAPPENING IT'S CAN YOU EARN
TODAY YOU CAN DO IT OR GRADUALLY
SPEED YOU MAY PLAY TO GO.
AND YOU CAN GET TO THE PRICE BOX
BECAUSE YOU KNOW WHAT YOU LIKE --
IT'LL WORK.
IT'S LIKE WE ALL DO AND SO HAVE
THOSE REPORTS FOR IT'S A
GORILLAPOD VISITOR.
THINGS THAT COME OUT OF THE WAY
SCAN AND WE TRACKED THE KID IN
THAT.
ARE THE SUPER SO WE'RE ADDING TO
THE AND THE STUDENT.
WILL BE IS IT GOING TO MAKE A
DIFFERENCE FOR THAT CHILD --
ARE THEY IN THEIR GOAL EVERY DAY
ARE WE SEEING BETTER.
HERE AND THEN ALSO IS THERE
SOMEONE NOT RECEIVE POP UP FROM
THE TEACHERS IN SS SAY HEY THIS
IS NOT DOING WELL COME SCHOOL
LATE WE CAN BRING THEM UP IN OUR
WELLNESS TEAM ALSO.
DOWN WITH IT CAN REACH OUT TO
THE FAMILY.
WHAT I REALLY APPRECIATE ABOUT
THAT IS ITS POTENTIAL SO THEY
DON'T COME BACK TELL ME YOUR THE
TEACHERS IS A PROBLEM?
THEY HAD LET BETTER SOMETHING I
CAN DO IS A SCHOOL DESPONDENT DO
THAT AS WELL.
OVER THE IS REALLY FOUR YEARS WE
CAN DO PROCESS --
I I I'VE SEEN SOME REALLY ROOM
RIGHT IMPROVEMENT IN TERMS OF
THE COMMON LANGUAGE.
TERMS OF HOW KIDS AT THE AND I
FEEL REALLY GOOD.
EVERYDAY ABOUT GOING THERE
BECAUSE ABSOLUTELY FANTASTIC THE
PLACE TO BE.
AND THEN THE FINAL THE ONE ACT
AT ABOUT TEACHER TRAINING.
IS A LOT OF TIMES TEACHERS NOW.
IT WAS THE AND WE DON'T ON THE
HOT SPOT AND DO THINGS ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT I'VE REALLY BEEN
WORKING ON IN TERMS OF* ONCE
IN THIS.
IS RESTORE PRACTICE IS TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT EXACTLY HAD BEEN
IN THE MOMENT IS THIS MONTH.
IS ONGOING BULLYING HOW.
TO SOLVE THIS PROBLEM SO THE
CHILD CAN GET BACK IN THE
CLASSROOM THE SUIT ON THE
RESTAURANT BECAUSE THAT'S
ALTERNATELY WORK TO DO.
AND WE TO ALL TO CREATE A LIST
OF SUPPORT TO TEACHERS HAVE SO
THE CHILD HAVING TROUBLE WITH
THAT WHETHER IT'S AN ACADEMIC OR
BEHAVIORAL AREA.
WHERE THEY GO TO GET SUPPORT
WHAT SOMEONE IS WE CAN BE WHO?
TO TALK TO US TEACHERS SO NOT
AND YOU WANT THE STUDENTS THE
PARENTS THINGS WE WANT TO GIVE
OUR FUTURE RESORT AS WELL.
BECAUSE OF THE TIME WHILE TIME
AGO -- WHEN
I FIRST BEGAN TEACHING I HAVE
VERY WISE PERSON TELL ME THAT?
WE'RE AT A JOB IS TO TEACH THE
TEACHERS TEACH AND TM AGAIN.
BUT THEY DON'T WANT TO THERE'S
CONSEQUAT.
SELECT LOOK AT THE TO WAIT WHAT
WOULD AND WHAT IS IT BECAUSE
THEY DON'T KNOW.
BECAUSE THEY WANT.
AND HOW TO GO ABOUT DOING IT
KATIE WHAT THEY'RE ITS TEACHER.
MISTREATED WHOEVER WILL WORK OUT
TO TRY TO TRADE AND CULTURES
BETTER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO THE ALSO.
IN A POP PLEASE CONGRATULATE YOU
FOR RECEIVING THE POSITIVE
BEHAVIOR INTERVENTION AND
SUPPORT COALITION IN A SILVER
THE WALK SO CONGRATULATIONS.
MUCH FLORA --
BE ABLE TO ACCOMPLISH SO MUCH
WITH A VERY LIMITED RESOURCES I
REALLY ENCOURAGE ME TO CARRY THE
BILL AGAIN NEXT YEAR TO MAKE
SURE.
THAT EVERY SCHOOL HOUSE OF
COUNSELING SERVICES MENTAL
HEALTH.
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WILL GO TO MAC AND BOTH OF THEM
ARE PRETTY MUCH UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT.
GETTING AUTUMN.
THANK YOU.
CHIU TH QUEUE FOR TENTATIVE COME --
AND ON THIS IMPORTANT TOPIC.
MY NAME IS MATT CAMPBELL THE
DIRECT STUDENT BUT SIR IS A NON
BEING OF OUR SUPER.
DOC CAME OFF AS WE ARE ON TO
PRESENT TO YOU WE DO AT SCHOOL
BACK.
I WANTED TO TAKE A DIFFERENT
APPROACH AND IS OF WE DO I THINK
THAT ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I'VE
HEARD OF THE PANELIST COOL.
THIRTY FIVE THIRTY SIX OUT
STUDENTS AND SO IT'S A PRETTY
DIVERSE BASED ON ONE CALENDAR
THAT WE HAD IN TERMS OF WHEN
STUDENTS REPORTED CLEAN.
A MOP FOR RESPONSIBILITY MY FOR
POSSIBILITY MATIC WAS TO TRY TO
CREATE A SYSTEM.
TERMS OF TWO EIGHT FIVE THE
DISTANCE OF A AS A COMMON
RESPONSE.
SO.
BUT I HAD TO DO IF POSSIBLE KNOW
THAT -- I'VE
BEEN WORKING IF --
THIS JUMP OVER HERE WE CREATED.
A RESPONSE REPORT AND N. F.
BUTTON ABOUT THIS I'M REALLY
REALLY AUTUMN WE DONE BECAUSE
REGARDLESS OF WHAT.
STUDENT PORTS LEAN --
THE FONTS IS IT GOING TO BE THE
SAME -- WHAT
YOU SEE RIGHT HERE WE'VE A LOT
TIME DEVELOPED IN THIS SYSTEM?
AND COMMUNICATED PROVIDING
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT SO WHEN
THE WE TALK ABOUT BEING SAFE.
AT THE ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WHEN PLANE AS REPORTED WHEN
SOMEBODY HAS THE COURAGE TO COME
PORTER PORTER THEN WHAT HAPPENS.
I CAN TELL YOU THIS AS A PARENT.
I EXPERIENCE THIS THAT I OWN AND
EXPERIENCE SOME BOWLING AND I
WAS SHOCKED AT THE LACK OF
RESPONSE IN TERMS OF WHAT CAN
BACK ME.
SO I CAN TELL YOU IN FACTLY AT
IN FREMONT IF A STUDENT OR A
CHILD OR A PARENT OF REPORTS
BULLYING.
THIS POWER ARE GOING TO THE
PROCESS AND FROM WHAT WE SO THE
IN FRONT VIEW IS.
ARE SAMPLING SOME A RESPONSE
FROM AN IS USED IS YOU CAN SEE
EVERY SCHOOLS IN SO AND EVERY
ADMIN STRAIGHTER AS THE LINK TO
THIS.
SPECIFIC FORM.
THAN IF IT'S OUT THERE FOR A
PARENT FOR REPORTS PULLING THAT.
THE ADMINISTRATION KNOWS THAN
TWENTY FOUR HOURS THEY HAVE TO
INITIATE A PORT INITIATE IN THAT
CATION.
SO YOU SEE THERE'S A DROP DOWN
MENU UP TOP THERE'S ALL TOOLS
THAT ARE LISTED THERE.
AND THAT ITS PURPOSE FOR THE IS
AT THE END OF EVERY AT THE END
OF EVERY SEMESTER I GIVE A
REPORT.
STRAIGHTER FROM THEIR PROJECT
THEIR SCHOOL SITES IN THE
HAITIAN THE DATE THE INS AND
OUTS OF THE AND THE IN.
AN ODD LOOKING IN.
ABOUT CALLED THE ALLEGED VICTIM
BUT WE STARTED WITH THE NAME OF
THE PERSON THAT'S FINE THE
COMPLAINT.
I DIDN'T OR AND THE RAID LOOK OF
THE COMPLAINT THE WHEN YOU KEEP
GOING.
FURTHER.
THAN WE HAVE MISSION ABOUT THE
RESPONSE IN THE WRIST AND IS THE
SENATE IS RESPONSE --
TO THE ALLEGATION.
SO THEN WHAT IS THE LEVEL THE
REST AND AND SO IF YOU KEEP
GOING THEN THEN WE CAN HAVE SOME
COMPARISON DATA.
SO.
AS YOU CAN SEE THERE IS THE
SUMMARY OF THE ALLEGED INCIDENT.
AND AND WE HAVE TRAINED
APARTMENT TRADER ON AND THE
PROFESSIONALS AND THEY CONDUCT
INVESTIGATION WANTED TO COMPILE
ODES HAVE THE CONVERSATIONS.
AN DAY NOW THAT THEY HAVE TO
MAKE IT BERMAN NAY AND WAS THIS
BOWLING INCIDENT BASED ON
PROTECTED ASSETS THE IN THERE IT
IS YES.
THEM DOWN THE OTHERS OF FEDERAL
ACTED AS IS --
AND THEN IT JUST BOX AGAIN
THAT'S REALLY REALLY FOR THE
NOTE.
IT IS WHO WHO IN OUR DISTRICT IS
IS -- ON THE
THEN THE THE PRINCIPAL NOTE THAT
THE PARENT C. R. U. C. P. ARE
YOU ONE COMPANY PROCESS AND
BECAUSE AND WRITE IT WANT TO
FILE.
A FORMAL COMPLAINT IF THERE ARE
DOUBLING INCIDENT BASED ON A
PROTECTED CLASS.
SO THEN AT THE END OF THAT THAT
THEY'RE IN THE GATE THEY NEED TO
MAKE A DETERMINATION.
BASED ON THE REPORTED INCIDENT
WHAT THEY CAN FIND OUT THROUGH
THERE TO GET FINDINGS.
IS IT YES OR NO AND THAT THE
NATION.
READ THE LIST OF WHETHER OR NOT
IT'S YET OR NOT.
IS WHAT I AM REALLY PROUD ABOUT
AND WHAT ARE IN THE SHAPE IS DUE.
IF YOU WILL ON STROLLING.
AND A ARE MINISTERS THE IN APP
PLAN BELL ACTION PLAN TO ACT.
DRESS THE BLAME.
SO THERE IS A LIST OF VENTURE.
WET THE SCHOOL HAS A CRISP BOLD
TAKEN BACK IN OR ALL THAT APPLY
WHAT THEY CAN IMPLEMENT AT THE
TOOLS AND SO THEN YOU CAN SEE.
A LOT LESS.
IF YOU FONG UNINSTALLING OUR
NEXT ONE IT WILL TO BE THE MACRO
VIEW.
TERMS -- YOU
KNOW WITH THEIR OR SOMETHING
GOING ON IN THE AND NEED TO PAY
ATTENTION TO AND THIS IS WHAT
THEY CAN DO SCHOOL AND SO COUPON.
BONDS BOWLING --
WHAT IS ACTION STEPS THEN THEY
TURN AS AN M. TRADED TO
PREVENTABLE IN?
AND YOU CAN SEE THAT THAT THAT
THERE IS A GOOD IDEA AND OVER
IDEA.
IS THAT IT SHOOTER CAN --
PUT INTO PLACE TO PREVENT THE
BULLY.
KEEP ON GOING.
SO HOW DO WE REMEDY THE EFFECTS
OF HER ASK FOR THE BOOK IN ON
THE COMPLAINT OR THE STUDENT
THAT IS BEEN ON THE RECEIVING
END OF BELONGING.
AND SO THEY CAN SEE YOU THERE.
AT FIRST BALL IT RIGHT THERE
SORT OF RECEIPT OR EMPLOYMENT
RESTORE BACK IS FOR THE FIRST
TIME IN OUR SCHOOL DISTRICT.
ON THAT IT WOULD EVER SECONDARY
LEVEL AND SO THEY CAN SEE WE CAN
PROVIDE RESOURCES TO OUR CAR
TEAM.
AND AND ALL THE ACCOUNT SERVICES.
THING THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT IS
THAT WE WERE EDUCATORS AND AND
THE GENTLEMAN RIGHT DOCTOR BUT
YOU KNOW WE WE HAVE TO TEACH
PEOPLE BEHAVIOR.
OF ONE MORE ONE LAST THING TO
KEEP CALLING.
THE IS THE ACTION PLAN AND TO
CARESS.
ACTIONS OF THE RESPONDENT THOUGH
WE COLUMN CORRECTIVE ACTIONS
RAIDERS CAME AND BUT THEY'RE
ALSO TO WITH.
THE THE ACT OF THE OF THE
RESPONDENT.
SO WHAT WE WE TRY TO DO IT FROM
A MORE THE FIRST LIVED UP WITH
THEM PUNITIVE AND SO THE BOTTOM
NOW WITH AREA IS --
IF THAT HAPPENS THE COVER THAT
IMPRESSES PENSION MOTION.
AND THEN.
DOWN AT THE VERY BY.
THIS IS.
THAT -- THAT
OUT.
IS THAT IF THEY'RE GONNA AT THE
FORM TO MEET AND I LOOK ONE UP.
AT I THINK THAT.
THE MISSING PIECE OF THAT SINCE
STUDENTS OF OUR TALKED IT IS.
WHEN SUIT REPORT SOMETHING LIKE?
SOMETIMES I DON'T HEAR ANYTHING
BUT IT DISTRICT THEY THEY HERE
BECAUSE OUR THAT IS OUT THERE
THE HOT LINK A HOWLING FOR LACK
OF BETTER TERM --
THE THE PARENTS TRIED THE ADMIT
AND IT'S A LETTER TO PARENTS.
AND THAT THE SOFTWARE THE ACTION
THAT THAT THE MINUTE OR TWO WHO
UP UNTIL INVESTIGATE --
OUR MINISTRY DEAL WITH A LOT.
AND IN PARTICULAR ASSET.
WE ENGAGE IN A LOT OF
PROFESSIONAL ABOUT FOR ARGUMENT
TRADERS AND MORE IMPORTANTLY.
THE READ THE PRO SADDAM INTO OUR
SITE AND SO ALL OF OUR TEACHERS
HAVE ANNA I'M AWARE IN TERMS OF
WHAT BILLION IS.
DEDICATED IF SOME OF HIS IN A
PUT DOWN THAN HOW THEY SHOULD
RESPOND TO IT.
SO A NUMBER OF TIME BUT STUCK
HOW WE DEAL WITH STUDENT SAFETY
ONE OF THE ONE OF THE WAY AND
FRIEDMAN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH [INAUDIBLE]
KEEP YOUR GOOD EVENING MY NAME
IS KENYA AT A SENATE THE
DIRECTOR STUDENTS IS THIS FOR
YOU UNION HIGH SCHOOL DISTRICT
I'M HERE --
REPRESENTED I DID CHECK AT THE
REQUEST OF MY SUPERINTENDENT
FONT AND EXCITED TO BE HERE.
I WILL LIVE COLLEGE AT TAKE A
DIFFERENT APPROACH CHINS BILL
AND WE TALKED OUR MY PRESENT THE
INFORMATION AND I ALSO ADDRESS.
I'M WHAT OUR APPROACH IS THE
DISTRICT BUT I FIRST WANT TO
COST US AND BEGAN TO HAVE A
STATE AROUND CLEAN THAT WE ARE
STATE AND WHAT BILLION REALLY IS
THAT WE DON'T OVER ANALYZE THE
USE.
OF THE WORD.
I'M AN UNDERSTANDING THAT I
SAFETY.
PHYSICALLY MENTALLY MOSTLY OR SO
WE ON A FREE A WRITTEN --
REQUIRES AN ACT.
BUT FOR THE SAKE WHEN I SPEAK
NIGHT I'M IS IN THE DEFINITIONS
ONE THAT ARE THAT DID NOT FIND
BILL THEY SWEPT FORTY THIRDS AS
AN INTERN TIONAL SPECIALIST.
AT BURKE AND PLAN IT INTERNET
RESEARCH AS WELL THE BILLS
BEFORE COMING LINK UNDERSTANDING
AVE IS SCOTT --
IN AS AN UNWANTED.
THAT'S DISPLAYED.
AS A PATTERN BEHAVIORS OVER THE
TOP.
AND BOTTOM AND MOST OF ORANGE
STRENGTH UP MY CUP SURE SHE
WOULD BEGIN SHE'S NOT BILL IS
NOT JUST A STUDENT WAS IMPORTANT
FOR US NOT STAND UP IN ANY TYPE
OF POWER.
OR ANY TYPE OF STRENGTH.
THAT IS LOVE WHO YOUR TARGET
WHERE THE ADULT OR STUDENT.
CLASSIFIED AS BOOK ABOUT THE
DEATH CHIN.
SO FOR CLARITY AND HAS A VERY
CLEAR DEVON BEN AS EDUCATE WE'RE
GOVERNED YET.
I WOULD COME IN WITH I THINK BY
STILL USE THE APPLE TO GOVERN
THE WORK THAT WE'RE DOING AND SO
BAD COLD IS BECAUSE THAT BOTH IN
IS THE V. ARM PERVASIVE VISIT.
OR ACT CLUED IN WRITING --
THAT INCLUDES THE OF COURSE
DON'T.
EXPECT IF OF DETRIMENTAL DON I'M
PHYSICAL OR MENTAL HEALTH --
EXPERIENCE NOTHING IS WITH A
STUDENT OR HER DEMI FOREMAN'S
AND THEN IT AFFAIR WITH HIS OR
HER ABILITY TO PARTICIPATE IN
ANY BUSINESS OR OR ACTIVITIES
ARE.
JUST.
BY THE SCHOOL I'M NOT SEEN
ANYTHING THAT DOESN'T MEET THIS
THRESHOLD IS NOT RELEVANT.
IS SAYING WE HAVE LOOSELY USE
THE WERE BULLYING SOMETIMES FOR
JUST BAD --
CHOICES ON KIDS PARKS AND
PEOPLE'S AND WORDS MATTER.
ON PEOPLE LATE GALORE I AM VERY
TO THE I'M AT RISK BECAUSE PUTS
RESPONSIBILITY STUDENTS STUDENTS.
FACTOR IS THERE A LOT IF.
THEY HAVE TO OVERCOME.
AS WE USE THE TERM --
A BUILDING ANNEX ONE OF YOUR WE
CLICK.
IT IS NECESSARY FOR YOU TO
ALWAYS RESPOND TO ANY NEGATIVE
ACT BUT WHEN WE USE THE TERM IN
THERE SOMEWHERE ISSUE NOT
RESPONSIBLE THESE ARE
REQUIREMENTS.
ON THAT YOU SHOULD BE IN TUNE.
TO DISTRICT --
WE ARE TRYING TO ENSURE THAT WE
CAN SEND IN UNIFORM ACROSS THE
ENTIRE --
DID TO ENSURE STUDENTS ARE
WELCOME AS THEY ARE.
THEY HAVE SUPPORT THEY NEED TO
BE THE AT THREE TWO OF THE NBA
DREAM --
SUCCESSFUL ALL OF THEIR VENTURE.
AND I SAY THAT TO SAY.
IN OUR DISH THERE ARE ARE WE ARE
HIGH SCHOOL ONLY DISTRICTS.
THE CITY.
WAS THAT THE ELEVEN
COMPREHENSIVE ONE ALTERNATE ONCE --
IN RECENT THE NECESSARY REASON
ABOUT THE THREE THOUSAND
STUDENTS.
SO TO ENSURE THE NOT WEARING
CONSISTENT COMMENT SAID THE POOR
AND THAT THERE IS SOME OVERSIGHT
TO THAT.
I AM MAD ON HERE IS --
WERE DOWN BY THE EASY WAY TO
ENSURE THAT THERE'S GOT STERN
AND THAT EVERYONE HAS BEEN OF
GREAT THIS OPPORTUNITY --
AND I DISTRICT I WANTED TO MAKE
SURE YOU'RE AWARE.
OF A BILLING.
IN THE FIRST.
SURE THAT THE PHYSICALLY MET AT
LEAST BILLION EMOTIONALLY HELP
YOU -- AT
THEY'RE DOING THAT THE NEXT STEP
IS TO DO A SEPARATE AND OR DOES
THE GEISHA.
OF THE INVESTIGATION PIECES ALL
EDUCATION.
TIMES HAVE TO EDUCATE THOSE OF
THE WAY ON WORDS THAT ARE BEING
YOU IS AT TIMES THAT THEY WERE
PROCEED.
SO IT'S IMPORTANT FOR THEM TO
CONDUCT THAT --
IF AN ISSUE TO AT THE BEGINNING
OF THE NATION IS UNFAIR TO ALSO
INVOLVED TACTIC HOUSE IN OUR
DISTRICT NOW HAVE A POSITION THE
DIRECTOR OF AT AND LIVE.
IN THE CITY --
IT WRITTEN A RESPOND TO IN.
OR OF BILLY HARAP AND THAT IT
TOWARD TECH BOMB PARENTS DO NOT
HAVE TO REQUEST THAT IS AN
AUTOMATIC USED TO BE AN OCCASION
THAT BINS --
TANDEM AT THE SAME TIME THAT
WILL SITE INVESTING
INVESTIGATING ISSUE.
I MEAN THE FAX THEM IN AND FROM.
WHAT THE INVESTIGATION TURNS
OVER THE NEXT STEP IS MAKE
DECISIONS ON APPROPRIATE
RESPONSES AND RESPONSES --
LAP WAS PREVIOUSLY STATED ISN'T
JUST FOR A STUDENT WHO IS
REPORTED TO HAVE IT'S A RESPONSE
ON ANY HELP SUPPORT AND ENGINE.
TO TEACH ME YEARS NOT ONLY TO
BOMB.
INITIAL COME TO TAKE YOU OVER
THE AGE OF AUDI ACCOUNTABLE --
WE ALSO INSURE THERE'S A LOT
THAT WE CAN MAKE SURE THAT.
OF PEOPLE MARK --
AS UNITY I WAS AT THE ADDRESS
HAS A COMMUNITY HOW CAN WE WORK.
WITH DRESS BY IT RECENTLY HAVE
TO SAY WE HAVE TO UNDERSTAND
THAT WE A RESPONSIBILITY OF
APPROPRIATE SUPPORTING STUDENTS.
WHO ARE ON THE SUBJECT OF WHAT
MAY BE MEMBER QUIRK CHOOSE THE
BULLION AS A MINUTE WE HAVE TO
MOVE BEYOND ENSURING OUR KIDS
ARE COLLEGE AND CAREER READY?
BUT ALSO MAKE THEM COMMUNITY
READY.
WE'RE NOT TAKING OUT WEAPONS AND
TO THE COMMUNITY ARE PUSHING OUT
TO ME.
AND THIS INCLUDES TEACHING
SUPPORT IMPROVEMENT ON SOCIAL
MOTIONAL.
ACCOMPLISH THESE HELPFUL ERNEST
MANAGEMENT RELATIONSHIP SKILLS
SOCIAL WELL AS A MATTER AS RISK
SUBORDERS MAKE.
I'M ALTHOUGH JEAN --
THESE COMMITTEES AS NATURAL
BETTER PARENTING I THINK IMPORT
SOME HELP TO DEVELOP THOSE
COMPETENCIES FOR ME I CALL THEM
OFF OUR L. THOSE ARE EXTRA LOVE
KIDS.
THOSE ARE KIDS BUT I'M NOT A
STAFF HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE. TO
ANAL ABOUT IT COMPETENCIES IN A
TIER ONE FORMAT AND THEY NEED
ONE ON ONE ATTENTION. TO IMPROVE
TO BE EIGHT YEARS CANNOT KILL
THE ISLAND FOR MAKE BAD CHOICES
WE CAN ENSURE.
THAT WE TEACH APPROACH BEHAVIORS
AS WELL HOLDING THEM ACCOUNTABLE --
AS A COMMUNITY OF THE TWO THAT
WE GET A CLEAR MESSAGE THAT HEY
IF YOURS ARE ON IT NOT
INDIVIDUAL STUDENTS --
BILLION IS A COMPLEX ISSUE IT IS
A COMPLEX RESPONSE THE RESPONSE
AFTER KLUBI EIGHT AGE
APPROPRIATE.
WE CANNOT POLICE PRESSED PRESSED
CHARGES OUT OF THIS WORK THIS IS
WORK WE HAVE TO GET IN THE
FOURTH ROUND UP.
AFTER WORKING ON PREVENT AS WELL
INTO INTERNET THE SAME EXACT
TIME -- IN
SHORT I'D SAY --
AS WE BILL CAPACITY ON OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE THEY WILL LEAD THE WAY
AND I I HAVE TO A POP EYES FOR
JUST COMMUTE IN JANET FOR TO THE
COMMUNITY IN GENERAL ON BEHALF.
OF THE LOOK OF LEAVE WE HAVE IN
THIS COUNTRY WILL NOW BE IT IS
PERPETUATING THE TOP THAT WE'RE
SITTING HERE TALKING.
TONIGHT.
GREEN [INAUDIBLE]
VERY MUCH.
BUT AT LEAST ONE OF THE HIM FROM
THE OF PROJECT CORNER STORE.
USE A MUCH AND IT'S AN HONOR TO
BE HERE ON THIS PANEL ON THESE --
THE EDUCATORS THAT ARE CLEAR
UNDERSTANDING THEM TO SCHOOL
CLUB MED AND EDUCATE THE WHOLE
CHILD.
OF THE PROJECT WAS DONE AS PART
OF THE YMCA.
SILICON VALLEY AND WE WORKED
ALONG SIDE SCHOOLS PROVIDING
THEM WITH TOOLS.
THAT WILL HELP IN THE REALM OF
PREVENTION AND I THINK THAT
WE'VE THAT THEME --
CREATED IN CLIMATE.
COMMITTING INCLUSIVE WE'RE
BUILDING BILL VALUE RESPECTED IT
NOW IS IMPORTANT.
ALSO PROJECT CORNERS AS A BOND
OVER THE LAST TWENTY YEARS OUR
PARTNERSHIP SCHOOLS HAVE
EXPANDED TO TWO HUNDRED WILL
REDWOOD CITY TO GO ALL RIGHT.
AND OUR PREVENTION EFFORTS ARE
ON TIME TO INCREASE.
TO REPORT OF THE COMMITTEE.
WHICH TO INCLUDE THE STAFF AND
THEN LATER.
YOU TRY INCLUDE STUDENTS BECAUSE
THEY'RE CRITICAL WE ALSO TRIED
IN THE PAST.
MOST OF OUR EFFORTS HAVE BEEN.
READING PORT EARLY EDUCATION SO
WE'LL BRING IN PRESCHOOL AND UP.
INTO THE MIDDLE SCHOOL YEAR
[INAUDIBLE]
WE ONE THAT USES A CHILDREN'S
BOOKS THAT BROUGHT IT THE
CLASSROOM EVERY MONTH.
AND THOSE.
WE HAVE TRAINED OVER FIFTY FIVE
PARENTS TO BRING THOSE BOOKS.
IN TWO ON IN ELEMENTARY PRE K.
CALL ROOMS --
LEADING PROCESS FROM THE BOOKS
THAT ARE EMPATHY ABOUT COM
RESOLUTION ABOUT PROBLEM SOLVED
THING.
ABOUT OF A BYSTANDER PULLING
SITUATION.
OF THE CURRICULUM IS AVAILABLE
NOT ONLY IN ENGLISH BUT ALSO IN
SPANISH --
SO THAT PARENTS WHO ARE
MONOLINGUAL CAN GATE KNOW BALL
CONNECTED --
IN THEIR CHURCH AND SCHOOL IT UP.
FOR V. --
THE FRIENDS WHO ARE VOLUNTEERING
WITH US OR ARE AND ENHANCING THE
CARRYING SCHOOL CLIMATE THAT
THIS TOPIC STRAIGHTER CREATING
AND THEY'RE THEY'RE CRITICAL
THERE ON THE FRONT.
AND THE STUDENTS ARE REALLY
HAVING A CANCER THE LESSON. TO
TO PRACTICE I'M I'M GLAD YOU
MENTIONED ALL THIS --
WHEN PREVENTION RESEARCH THAT WE
CAN'T EXPECT KIDS OR ADULTS TO
DISTANCE TING WE KNOW HOW TO ACT
IN RESPONSE ATTITUDE EIGHT THEY?
GET A CHANCE TO BE --
AN ARM TOP AND ENTERPRISE.
ROLE PLAYS --
IN THREE DIFFERENT ACTIVITIES
STONE BY BETTING THAT INTO --
INTO OUR SENSE OF THE KIDS --
BILL IN THE VOCABULARY AND
BEFORE BEING FIRST AND BY HAVING
PARENTS AND GAPED AND TM LESS
THAN IT ALSO BEING BROUGHT BACK
INTO THE HOME ENVIRONMENT AS
WELL.
WE HAVE ANOTHER COMPONENT CALLED
A RESPECT.
KIDS THE CHANCE --
TO IN A FIRE SO WE'VE HEARD
ALLEN LEAVE FROM THIS THE YOU
WERE SITTING IN THESE RECEIPTS.
OTHER ONES EXPERT EVERYDAY
PROBLEM.
SO FOR THEM TO BE.
OF A SAFE PLACE TO ARTICULATE
WHAT IS HAPPENING AND THAT COULD
BE A LEAD CHANGE SO THAT IT
COULD BE DIFFERENT.
ARE SO EXPECT RESPECT PROGRAM
TAKE A WITHIN A SCHOOL FOR FIFTY
KEY INFLUENCERS --
OF THE STUDENT POPULATION LEASED
PER WORKSHOP OR THERE I DON'T
MIND THIS HAPPENING ON THEIR
CAMPUS.
THEY ARE THEN --
SOME STRATEGIES AND DEVELOP
ACTIONS AND IS THEN CARRIED OUT
OVER THE REST OF THE YEAR WITH
THE SUPPORT OF COAST OFF AS WELL
AS WITH.
THE SUPPORT OF PARENTS NICK
TODAY.
AND THOSE LEADERSHIP SKILLS ARE
SO IMPORTANT AND OUT.
SHINGLE FROM THE MOTION BILLS AT
EARLY AGE --
THOUGH AND UP A LITTLE SAMPLE OF
SCUTTLE THE SCHOOL CURRICULUM
THEY WERE USING UP A HOW TO
RECOGNIZE HER UP AND REPAIR
MICROGRAPHS AND BRING THE
COURAGE TO DO THAT IS NOT
SOMETHING THAT A HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENT IS DISTANCING TO LIKE.
TO KNOW WHAT THEY CAN LEARN FROM
THE THE TOOL AND A CAT VERY.
WRECKING HIS INTERRUPT ADDRESS
FROM THE DROP.
FIVE ALL THE WAY UNTIL THEY'RE
IN HIGH SCHOOL.
MORE LIKELY TO BE A PHONE YEARS
WE TO DO.
UP ONE SHOT.
AND WORKSHOPS BUT WE ALSO HAVE A
SIX WEEK SERIES WHERE WE HAVE
PARENTS GO MUCH MORE DEEPLY INTO
HOW THEY ARE.
DEALING WITH THEIR OWN CHILDREN
AS WELL AS ALL KIDS ARE KIDS
KIND OF A BIT.
TOO BECAUSE IT REALLY DOES TAKE
A VILLAGE AND THEN STOP
RECIPROCAL THE SUCCESS OF WHAT
THE CLIMATE IS AND I'M REALLY
PROUD OF THE WORK THAT'S
HAPPENED IN SANTA CLARA COUNTY
AND UP -- TO
SAN MATEO COUNTY WHERE WE WORK
AS WELL THAT DO YOU FEEL THAT
YOU HAVE --
A WONDERFUL LEADER TO RECOGNIZE
FORMS OF THIS WORK.
SO I'M GONNA SHOOT YOU --
ANOTHER SORT OF TERM FACTSET
LEAVE OF THE PRIDE CORNERS AND I
WAS REMINDER OF THE THE
DISTRIBUTORS WERE TOP BEING.
ABOUT THREE YEARS AGO THERE WAS
AN INCIDENT AT LINCOLN HIGH
SCHOOL.
WHERE STUDENTS --
IT HAD CHOSEN TO CALL THEM
INSTAGRAM ACCOUNT THAT INCLUDED
A LOT OF SEX BEING.
THE RIGHTS OF THAT STORY IS THAT
THE STUDENTS WERE THE TO SHUT
DOWN.
NOT THE MINISTER THERE'S THE
STUDENT DECIDED THAT IT NOT
THAT'S THAT'S NOT THEIR IDENTITY
THIS IS NOT WHO.
A CRITICAL MASS OF ELEMENTARY
AND MIDDLE SCHOOLS GETTING INTO
IN THE PROJECT CORNERSTONE
PARTNERS SCHOOL.
THAT'S REALLY THE OF THE
INCREMENTAL APPROACH TO CREATING
SOCIAL CHANGE I BELIEVE IS THAT
WE'VE GOT TO START YET AND THEN
HOW THESE FIREMAN REINFORCING
TEACHING RIGHT PURSING AT
TEACHING [INAUDIBLE]
SO.
REMEMBER YOU YOU ASKED THE
QUESTION.
OF WHY SHOULD YOU BE TEACHING
BROWN CHILD.
I'LL START NOW.
HOME WORK ON TEACHING THE
SCHOOLS AND HOW TO REALLY STAND
EXPERTS THE FEELING THAT THEY'RE
THEY'RE HOUSE THING --
YOUR STAND WHAT CAUGHT LIKE
LOOKS LIKE AND UNDERSTANDS
SKILLS OF HOW TO ADDRESS --
AND DEAL WITH CALL ACT AND THEN
THAT REALLY CRITICAL MESSAGE OF
HOW CAN WE ADULTS OKAY.
THERE'S YOUTH.
CHIP IN A BY STATE --
WHEN THE THE THING ROBBING THE
WORLD IN ALL TO BECOME AN UPS --
I'LL JUST CLOSE BY SAYING THAT
IN THESE DAYS OF SO MUCH
DARKNESS --
LEADER BUT AND ALLOW.
THEIR SO.
MANY BRIGHT SPOTS NOT UNITY THE
GIVE GREAT HOPE AND I REALLY DO
BELIEVE NEXT VERSION OF YOU.
ARE GOING TO MAKE A PROJECT
CORNERSTONE HAVE FORESTS TO SORT.
A DIFFERENT SCHOOLS.
I WAS.
WHY AM C. METRO BOARD?
THIS THE RIGHT NUMBER COLUMN C.
A. SILICON VALLEY.
THE NAME WAS SMILING CAME UP
WHILE I WAS ON THE BOARD WHEN WE
TAKING UP ON THIS PRODUCT BUDGET
CONGRESS GOING TO THOSE BACK IN.
NINETEEN NINETY NINE AND EARLY
TWO THOUSANDS AND NOW WE'RE
READING OVER EIGHTY SIX THOUSAND
YOUTH IN OUR COMMUNITY WAS
ALMOST. TWENTY YEARS AGO.
THANK LAW OKAY I'M FLUX WITH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE YOU ALSO.
SAYING DO YOU.
TO PEOPLE IN THE AUDIENCE THAT
HIGH QUALITY TO ADDRESS TO DO
THIS -- AND
UP TO RECOGNIZED THE OF FRANKLY
MCKINNEY SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER
[INAUDIBLE]
AYE MONA.
IS ALSO WITH US.
TODAY SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PICTURES AND ALL WOULD JUST.
OF A PUBLIC COMMENTS AND ANY YOU
BUDDY WALLET THROUGH COME AND
ADDRESS THE US --
PLEASE -- IT
IS SELDOM THAT WE HAVE.
PRESENTERS THAT ARE THIS
PREPARED ACROSS THE BOARD SO
THANK YOU FOR THAT BECAUSE IT'S
REALLY THAT REALLY MAKES.
EVERY MOMENT OF IT THIS WAY WHAT
UP FOR US --
NOT NOT WITHSTANDING THE THE
VERY.
OF OF THE ISSUE ITSELF.
YOU WANT TO SEE ON THE PUBLIC.
SIDE YOU KNOW.
THE BENEFIT OF OF UP TO DATE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S WELL.
BUT NO WITH MIL PAETUS.
IS IS ONE OF THE OPEN.
A MEASURES ELEVEN THIRTEEN NOW
BUT DISTRICT TO HAVE OF
SCHOOLING SIR IS --
THROUGH THE COUNTY WHICH DOES A
LOT OF OF WHAT MR LEACH WAS.
TALKING ABOUT WITH BUT ACTUALLY.
KNOW WHAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
LEGISLATION IN TERMS OF PUTTING
LOCAL FOLKS AN ACCESS ROAD ON
CAMPUSES BUT THERE'S OVER THIRTY
EIGHT AND OFFERS HE INVESTED BY
THE IN THE AM THANKS TO THE MET.
MILL HALL SERVICES ACT.
OF THE YEAH I WOULD SAY.
AND FOR THE ACTUAL.
MARKING OF MONEY THAT IS THAT
ISN'T THAT.
YOU MIGHT.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
IT TAPS.
LEGISLATION THAT WOULD --
EITHER REWARD STRICT OR PUT ME
ON THE TEEN MHS IT MONEY EIGHT
MONEY THAT'S ALREADY MADE
AVAILABLE. TO YOU THE ISSUE THAT
YOU'RE IN A COMICAL HOPE IN
SCHOOLS AND TRYING TO THINK THAT
WE'RE DAY SO --
YOU OBVIOUSLY INVOLVED IN.
BEST OF THE BEST PEOPLE WHO ARE.
YOU KNOW PRETTY COMMITTEE THAT --
I WOULD SAY.
NOT EVERYONE IS --
WE HAVE THAT ARE STILL KIND OF
OBLIVIOUS TO WHAT RESPONSES ARE
OR IMPOSE ON THEM AT ALL THAT
HE'S BEEN IN JUNE YOU WERE NOT.
BORN OKAY PERFECTION.
AT ANY POINT.
BUT THE BUT WILL WORK RING FROM
THE STUDENTS --
AND OTHERS --
IN IN THE FOR THE FOR PANEL.
IS -- THE
DESPITE OUR BEST EFFORTS WITH.
YOU WERE UP AGAINST IT WERE UP
IS IT PART OF A DISK I'M PART OF
IS WHAT WE'RE HEARING.
KNOW WHAT'S WHAT'S WITH IN
BECAUSE IT THAT THIS LEVELS OF
GOVERNMENT --
BUT THANK YOU UP IN IT THE POINT
IS THAT WE HAVE TO MINUTES.
AVAILABILITY OF LOCAL RESOURCES
INTO SOMETHING SENT STATE
RESOURCE IF THERE FOR US TO TO
THIS AREA.
THOUGHT THE PROPEL COMMENT BY
ONE OF THE STUDENTS OF THE ONE
ONE THE MOST PROFOUND MOMENTS
WAS.
THE STOP.
BUTTON WEARING SPORT WORRYING
ABOUT WHAT PEOPLE ARE SAYING
ABOUT WHAT WE'RE WEARING IN IT'S
JUST THE DIFFERENCE IN FOCUS --
IT DOESN'T REQUIRE MORE MONEY TO
DO THAT WHO REQUIRES CULTURE
CHANGE SO THANK YOU SO MUCH OF A
I'LL BE PEERS VERSION OF HIS
HEAD LEAVE. TO HEAR THE REPUBLIC
COMMA AND BUT I WANT TO THANK
YOU NOW.
TIME FOR CONVENING THAT'S THE
SCARY HERE INSTEAD OF KERN
COUNTY. TO REPLY TO ROB WORKING
WITHOUT IN UP TO THIRTY ACTUALLY
THE PHONE [INAUDIBLE]
A CALL.
THE PEOPLE THAT THAT --
ONE TO ADDRESS THIS PANEL
[INAUDIBLE]
CALL THE THANK.
YOU SIR HE A BE COMPARABLE TO
THE A FEW.
THE HELPFUL I THINK TO THE
MICROPHONES OF OUR THE ALL.
MY NAME OFF VIA.
I KNOW OFF YEAH.
THE A PARENT OF THREE I WOULD
LIKE TO SAY THAT FROM EACH
REGION.
IN CALIFORNIA BOUGHT
[INAUDIBLE]
I DON'T.
THE THE BOOKING SOME.
GRIEVED AND THIS CALL TO ALLOW
EMOTION.
THERE WAS A CLEAN STOP ME AT MY
OFFICE AND WE WILL TALK
DISCUSSED CUSSING AT THE CLOSE
OF LIFE.
AND THERE'S A BOX OF FROM BOTH
COLOR AND EVERYBODY IS.
I'M HAS SOME HAS.
A SIXTEEN SOME.
THIRTY NO. TO SAY YES TO WENT.
THEY HATE CRIMES IS.
MAKE.
SURE I UNDERSTAND.
THE FLOW OF THESE CHILDREN THERE
ARE FEW.
WE ARE ALREADY SAYING WHAT.
I MEAN ARE.
PRESIDENT OF AMERICA IS A
BILLION [INAUDIBLE]
THE THESE ARE GOING TO BE THESE
CHILDREN [INAUDIBLE]
SINCE.
YEAH.
SURE DOT.
IN EVERY WAY POSSIBLE. THREE
FROM THE THAT AND THEN TAKE.
WE STRUCK SOME BOOKS THEM.
PARENTS THE TO EDUCATE THE
CHILDREN TO HAVE.
BEEN RESPECT FOR EACH AND EVERY
UNDER [INAUDIBLE]
RACE ETHNICITY.
THESE ARE JUST MY TWO CENTS AND
BELIEVE THAT AS A PARENT.
I WOULD LIKE TO GIVE THAT MY
CHILD AND IT'S ALL A CHANCE I
WOULD -- AS
A P. T. AS A WALLET OR I'M
TRYING TO DO WHAT I WHERE I
CAN'T I'M TRYING TO BE A ROLE
MODEL FOR MY FILE AND I WOULD
LIKE. TO DO IS IN.
IT.
IS AN SAYING.
THANK YOU [INAUDIBLE]
BERMAN SHOULD.
I LIKE THE OF OF CLOTHES JUST
REMEMBER.
JUST JUST.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
HAS SAID THAT YOU KNOW DOES IT
NEED TO BY THE PROBLEM BUT SIX
MINUTE -- IS
THAT MEN.
OF COLOR.
THAT THE YOU KNOW SANTA IT DOES
A GOOD JOB GOING.
TO TEMPLE WHICH IS AN ON THE GO.
TO THE WI CAME ABOUT AS SUBTLE
AS WELL SON WAS GOING TO THE
POLICE AT ME.
AND ONE OF THE DIVERSITY ENDING
TENET.
WHAT WAS TEACHING THE CORAL?
DANTE ON MERLYN QUIMBY THERE'S
ALSO ISLAMIC MOSQUE.
SO MY SON ACTED AT SAY NO WAY
WERE FROM INDIA AND YOU KNOW
WE'RE SEATS AND IS CALLED THE
LARA.
HE CAME AND TOLD ME ABOUT.
AND YOU KNOW.
WE FELT THAT THERE WAS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR US WHO LACK WITH
ACADEMY.
AND WE DID AND EVER SINCE THEN --
EVERY QUARTER STRESS BASED AND
WANT TO BE VICTIMS AND WANT TO
DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT.
YOU KNOW WHETHER IT IS THE INTO
PRE.
OR OTHER COMMUNITY.
THAT WILL DO THIS ALONG.
WITH IT THAT YOU THINK THIS IN
HERE.
AT OUR WILL HELP FROM YOU.
ARE SO VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANNEX ALIVE TO YOU BY A MY MONA
BURDA.
HIS OF FRIENDLY MECHANIC SCHOOL
BOARD MEMBER.
GOOD EVENING MY NAME BUT OCTOBER
A MISSED SLUDGE OCCASION IT.
AT THE GOVERNING BOARD MEMBER
AND IN SANTA FE.
AND I WANT TO SHARE EXPERIENCE
BECAUSE IT.
IT'S TO THE X. TOPIC.
TODAY AND HOW SHE THIRTY
ACTUALLY WORK BEEN ABLE TO WITH
MY ENTITY DO.
I WAS TERM BECAUSE THIS SCARF
THE HEADS UP I JUST WALKED
AROUND MY HEAD.
THE PART OF MY RELIGIOUS BELIEFS.
SAME LEAVE THAT CALL ON ME AS A
MUSLIM INTERACT WITH IT VISUAL
MY STUDENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES.
THE MOST COMPASSIONATE IN PEACE
MANNER.
YOU'RE IN TOTAL WE EXPERIENCED
FIFTEEN INCIDENTS OF TARGET HATE
AT MY SCHOOL SITE.
I JUST HAVE HELPED HER FAMILY
MATIC IT IS TO BE VIOLATED AND
IT'S LIKE HER WHOLE.
IT IS IMPORTANT FOR YOU TO KNOW
THAT I GREW UP IN EAST AS A AND
CONTINUED TO TEACH IN THE SAME
COMMUNITY DOWN THIS TO MY CHILD.
I HAD EXPERIENCED HATE LIKE THIS.
IT WAS TEST AND TOGETHER AND
RESPOND TO HATE AND MUCH PROJECT
BASED LEARNING IT'S A LOT STATE
INNARDS EXPLORE.
TABS.
ON BEST NEXT WORK WITH I IN THE
TO DO NOT WORK.
WE PUT OUR INVITED YOU NEED AT
LARGE AND HAD A TIRE STAFF
ENGAGE AND I'M RETURNING.
AS A TEACHER. FOR UP TO CONTINUE
HAVING SOME CONVERSATIONS. TO
SUPPORT THOSE WHO CONTINUE TO BE
IMPACTED HATE AND WE NEED TO
TAKE.
A CLASS ACTION.
ACTION TO MAKE SURE PORTING
CHAIR IS LIKE MYSELF ON THE
GROUND BECAUSE THESE INCIDENTS
HAPPEN.
AND I SEE THEM HAPPEN COSTUMES
EACH AND EVERY SINGLE DAY
[INAUDIBLE]
ALL.
RIGHT NOW THERE'S NO.
THANK YOU I LOVE THIS TOPIC.
IN THAT I WAS ACTUALLY A BULLY.
IT'LL SCHOOL AND HIGH SCHOOL.
DID NOT PEOPLE CARRY GUNS AND
NOT.
ME.
AND HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY AND THE
AND MICHAEL TRACK HERE IN THE
CASE OF THE CLASS.
WHICH I'M VERY VERY BAD ABOUT.
AS A PREVENTION SPENT THE LAST.
TWO YEARS THE THIS.
IS FILLED WITH STUDENTS.
THIS IS JUST.
ONE FROM.
THE AGE BEDS BUT WHAT BUT WHAT I
CAME IN TEACH ATTACK.
I'M JUST READ AT THAT AT THE END.
BECAUSE I ON HOW.
TO BEING LIED AND BURKE
[INAUDIBLE]
BECAUSE THERE.
SO I WAS ABLE.
TO I CALL BACK AND THAT I WAS A
NINETY NINE SCHOOLS SESSION. FOR
TEN WEEKS.
THROUGH SALMON I CAN'T SAY I
WANT.
YOU A PLAN THAT WOULD.
AT THE SAME [INAUDIBLE]
BUT I YEAH [INAUDIBLE]
IT'S I MEAN POP DON'T BE A BULLY
AND RIGHT TO THE RIGHT.
THANKS.
VERY NICE.
YOUR ACT.
YOU DON'T WANT TO BE SOMEONE.
WHEN THE BACK?
ARE YOU DOING.
TO YOU'D BE MUCH HAPPIER IF YOUR
BEST NICE.
STOP BEING. TO HI.
A SINCE.
WEISS.
WHAT BE?
SATISFIED YOUR SHINS PEOPLE CAN
HAVE EXTREMELY SAD REACT.
STOP HER.
LATEST SMALL.
FIX THIS BEFORE THEY LEFT IN THE
MAN DIDN'T AND I DO HAVE TO TELL
YOU I'VE SPENT MOST OF MY LIFE.
ACTUALLY EIGHTEEN EIGHTEEN AND
HAVING TO GO BACK AND WRITE MY
WRONGS.
I TELL.
AND GETTING TOGETHER AT THE
MEETING.
WHERE THE FAMILY?
IT'S WIN WIN SITUATION WHAT.
EIGHT TEN AND AT TEN SLIP ALSO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK.
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR SERVICE
ANNEX WILL HELP TEAM --
RISKS ARE REAL [INAUDIBLE]
I'M SORRY [INAUDIBLE]
MEMBERS [INAUDIBLE]
HELLO.
I'VE HAD.
THE PRIVILEGE OF KNOWING BOTH --
CANCER AND SHE AND DAVE
PROTECTED SEE AND HIS WIFE PATTY
CASEY FOR MANY MANY YEARS.
I'M I'M.
SURE IN FACT THIRTY SCHOOL
DISTRICT BUT I'M ALSO CO FOUNDER
OF PUBLISHING THE IS CAP CORNEA.
I RESET. TO A TASTY DAVE CORTESE
KANSEN -- TO
MANY PEOPLE I COULD REACH OUT.
TWO YEARS AGO WHEN MY OWN SON
WAS SO SEVERE HE OF BIG TERM OF
HATE CRIME.
US ALSO BELIEVE.
HE HAD BEEN HOSPITALIZED.
ON MORE THAN ONE UP HERE THEM.
AN ALSO HOSPITALIZED --
SAFETY SCHOOLS BEST THING COURT
EASY FOR HELP IN THE TOURS
SACRAMENTO BECAUSE IN OUR USE.
THAT.
FOR AND THEN ASSEMBLY LIKE YOU
THAT WE HAVE OUR SANTA CLARA
COUNTY --
YOU REALLY LISTEN TO THEM AND IT
MAKES ALL THE DIFFERENCE AT A
DAY.
JUST LET.
MY DAUGHTER GRADS DIDN'T
COMMUNITY THAT HE'S.
AN SANTA.
AND ADDING THAT DIFFERENCES I'M
SURE THANK YOU. TWENTY THREE
ANNEX PHONE [INAUDIBLE]
COMMITTEE AGE.
IS ONE OF THE LIGHT THREE EIGHT
PROJECTS THAT WE ARE WORKING I'M
TO DRESS WILLING. TO THE FIRST
ONE IS THE SCHOOL BULLY RAY.
EVERY TWO YEARS AS A REMINDER
ENGINE WE LEASE EIGHT AM.
CHECK OUT FOR THIS IS A SCHOOL
BOWLING REPORT.
WHICH THE TYPE AND THE FREQUENCY
PULLING HER* MEANT THAT
AMERICAN.
STUDENTS.
IN PUBLIC SCHOOLS.
THE SURVEY ASKS ABOUT AT ODIN'S
ABOUT THEIR SCHOOL FIREMEN AND
WHETHER THEY HAVE EXPERIENCED OR
WITNESSED SCHOOL BOOK CAMPUS.
A SECOND ALONG THAT SURVEY WE'RE
ALSO PROTECTING RIGHTS.
WITH STUDENTS. TO PRESENT IN
FOCUS IS GLOBAL LOOKS WHAT
STUDENTS DO AYE WESTON SHOULD
NOT -- AND
TM THIS PRESENTATION PLUGGABLE
TO ALL STUDENTS JUST.
SO IF YOU.
WOULD BE ABLE TO YOU WHO IN YOUR
POSITION.
I MEAN PERHAPS COORDINATE.
I'M BECAUSE I'M A SOURCE AT THE
BOARD CAN THEM FROM THE TEACHERS
THEY DON'T UNDERSTAND OR KNOW
HOW -- TO
ASSIST STUDENTS TO WILL BE
AVAILABLE IN RESOURCE TABLE
BEHIND ME.
PICK ONE UP HOPEFULLY THIS --
CAN BE SOMETHING WE CAN WITH --
TO HELP AT A READING SCRIBBLING
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH YOUR KID
PROVIDE A LOT OF SERVICES AND
AND INFORMATIONS.
WHO WAS TO OUR COMMUNITY A LAST
BUT NOT LEAST SIX TRUE SIR
CASTELLANO?
SHE IS ALSO SERVED ON THE SLT
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT REPORT --
TRUSTEE. FOR EIGHT TO FIVE I'M I
COME IN AND BACK OF THE GREEN I
THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT.
I THINK THAT.
WE ARE TWENTY TWO YEARS TO HEAD
OF DEMOGRAPHIC EIGHT UP THE REST
THE CONDUCT OF THE THINGS THAT
WE KNOW THE STATE.
BUT I DON'T THINK THAT WE'RE
IMMUNE FROM ALL THE AND I M.
GRANT AND A WOMAN ENTITLED TO BE
HE AND HAVE BURKE AMERICA AND
WORKING CLASS.
HAPPY NATION AND AND SO I THINK
WE STILL HAVE TO DO OUR WORK AT
IS IT INTO THE STANDS.
THEY'VE BUILDING HOPE BECAUSE I
THINK THAT.
TO HAVE TO DO MORE THAN WHAT WE
ARE LEADER.
I PLEASE READ WHAT THE
RECOMMENDATION THE YOUNG WILL
HAVE ABOUT NEXT SEASON
UNDERSTAND EACH OTHER.
OUT BEING ABLE TO ABOUT THINGS
AND I THINK THAT WE DO HAVE TO
GET SOME KIND OF STATEWIDE
DOCUMENTING.
AND THE VARIETY OF THAT BECAUSE
I SOMETIMES SCHOOL DISTRICT
MIGHT GET.
IN IS THE THE HATE CRIME IS THAT
HATE INCIDENT ASSEMBLY INCIDENT
I THINK WE HAVE TO TALK ABOUT
DIVERSITY OF WAYS THAT THE
VIOLENCE IS TAKING PLACE.
OUR OUR STUDENTS.
TION OF OUR SOCIETY THERE BETTER
THE CURRENT SOCIETY AND WE DO
OUR WORK AND IN. TO ENSURE THAT
THEY WILL BE BETTER THAN THE
CURRENT DURATION OF THE DAY.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH DEFINITELY.
THE THING IS BY SOON I MIGHT
CALL THE US CARO UNDERSTAND
THERE'S A LOT OF WORK AHEAD OF
US.
AND THAT'S WHY WE HAVE THOSE --
OF PHONE TWO AND TO EDUCATE EACH
OTHER ON THE PHONE ON THIS ISSUE
AT MY OFFICE IS DEFINITELY --
OPEN ANYBODY WHO HAVE ANY GOOD
BILL IDEAS AND SUGGESTIONS I OF
A INTRODUCE ALL MY A STAFF
MEMBER BILLS FROM.
A SACRAMENTO AT DID YOU HAVE ANY
CLOSING COMMENTS.
NO TO SE AGAIN I COME IN
MICHAEL'S ENCOMPASS EARLIER BUT
I'M.
IN THANK YOU VERY MUCH CHIN YOU
TO ALL.
WHO ATTENDED THEM IN EVEN THOSE
WHO HAD THE HAD TO LEAVE ALREADY --
SHE IS VERY MUCH A PATERNAL.
THINKING MUCH SAYING.
RIGHT MEETINGS CONCLUDE KIMBERLY
DO YOU HAVE A THING TO SAY.
NO SIX VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
PATIENCE.
BEHAVIORAL [INAUDIBLE]
THERE [INAUDIBLE] OH OKAY
[INAUDIBLE]
YEAH [INAUDIBLE]
YEAH